hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i am
very pleased today to be sitting with my
good friend
daniel schmochtenberger who is the
founder of the consilience project
there's a lot more that i could say
about you daniel but i think we will
leave it at that for now
people can look up your bio if they want
to do so
i should probably start by telling
people that when i say that you are my
good friend i really mean that
you and i are good friends although to
be honest we haven't spent all that much
time together
this is one of those cases where you
meet somebody
somebody who has started from a very
different place and you discover that
you have all kinds of thought processes
that have reached similar conclusions
and
uh every discussion is fascinating the
more i learn about what you think
the more i realize i've got a lot to
learn from you and that there is
uh essentially infinite ground to be
covered so welcome daniel
thank you brett it's really good to be
here i feel the same way that
um we were introduced by our friend
jordan hall
and uh we've never had a conversation
where i
didn't learn something and where i
didn't appreciate the
good faith way that you showed up when
we had a disagreement to talk through
which is always
fun it is always fun and and i must say
i did a little bit of
poking around seeing recent interviews
you'd done but i
deliberately did not overly study for
this my sense is that the audience will
get a great deal
out of uh hearing you and me go back and
forth and
finding out what we agree on where we
disagree and
maybe most tellingly there's a
phenomenon
in which anybody who has learned to
think
more or less independently tends to have
their own
language for things their own set of
examples that they use to explain
things that recur over and over again
and so
in order to have high quality
conversations uh there is this
this period in which you're effectively
teaching the other person how you
phrase things and seeing those things
line up is great
and in the rare case where they don't
line up it's even better because you
know there's something to be learned one
way or the other
so i'm hoping that will emerge here i'm
looking forward to it
all right good so let's start here
when i say that you and i come from
different starting points
i i mean to imply something
in particular you as i understand it
were
home schooled and as you have described
it that was actually closer to what most
people would probably refer to
as unschooling somehow this did not
mess up your motivational structures
your parents were alert about what they
were doing and so
you ended up pursuing what you wanted to
pursue
and it did not you did not get in your
own way
and lo and behold you end up a
wickedly smart independent
first principles thinker
now that's not my story at all my story
is i went to school
and it didn't work i had something that
most people would
call a learning disability and it got in
the way of
school functioning for me and more often
than not i got
dumb tracked and basically that complete
failure of school to reach me
accidentally worked like some kind of
unschooling i would say
and so there are maybe many paths i
don't know
but i'd be curious four people who have
traveled some
road to the land of high quality
independent thought what can they expect
the experience to be
like when they arrived there
the experience of high quality
independent thought
yes if you imagine that well it would be
lovely to think independently
and to do so well and the world is going
to be a paradise if you start doing that
because of course
that's a very desirable thing to do and
people will appreciate it
you're going to be surprised that's not
necessarily what happens when you arrive
there and certain experiences show up
all over the place and without telling
you what my experiences might have been
i'm curious
as to what you might have encountered
and whether or not those things will be
similar
ah yeah it's an interesting question
uh i think you will experience
most people will experience a higher
degree of uncertainty
than people that are part of any
camp that has figured most things out
and they can cognitively offload whoever
the authorities or the general group
consensus is
um and certainty is
certainly comfortable in a particular
way
and if you're really thinking well about
what is my basis for what i believe what
is the epistemic grounding what's the
basis of my confidence margin
and you really think about your
confidence basis clearly
as you try to find more information to
deepen the topic
the known unknowns expand faster
like at least at a second order to what
the uh
known knowns do and so you keep being
aware of more stuff that you don't know
that you know is relevant and pertains
to the situation
so there's a complexification of thought
there's an
increase in uncertainty hopefully
there's an emotional development
and kind of a psychological development
where there's an increased comfort with
uncertainty
so that you can actually be honest and
not
uh defect on your own sense making into
premature certainty that creates
confirmation bias
and there's also a and i think that's
why
one of the reasons used term independent
um
there is a certain aloneness of not
having
a whole camp of people that think very
similarly
um
i don't find that to be a painful thing
right
but it's a thing no it's actually in its
own way
uh it's freeing because
the fact is if you follow
logic to natural conclusions
you'll end up saying a lot of things
that uh
are alarming or discordant with the
conventional wisdom
and the world neatly divides into people
who will be
so enraged or thrown by what you're
saying
that they uh disappear or
maybe they become antagonists at a
distance and the people
who have a similar experience and
therefore aren't thrown by the fact that
you're saying things that are out of
phase and so
editing the world down to those who are
comfortable with what they don't know
who are interested
in following things where they lead
irrespective of
who that uh elevates and and who it uh
um hobbles those people are interesting
people to hang out with
and so yes the uh the alienation
may be a blessing in disguise in some
ways
there's two other thoughts that came up
as you're just talking one is
i i wouldn't call myself an independent
thinker
i'm being particular about the semantic
of the word independent i wouldn't call
anyone an independent thinker because i
think in words
invented by other people i think in
concepts invented and discovered by
other people
i don't necessarily have a specific
school of orthodoxy
from which i take an entire world view
but almost every idea that i believe in
i did not discover
and so uh
i think that's a very important concept
because i think the
the ideas we're going to discuss today
regarding democracy
and open society have to do with the
relationship between an individual and a
collective
and i think the i there
the idea of an individual is
fundamentally a misnomer without
everybody else i wouldn't be who i am
and i wouldn't think the way i think i
wouldn't think in the language i do i
wouldn't have access to
you know the knowledge that came from
the hubble telescope and the large
hadron collider and so many things like
that
um so i can say that there is a certain
like ultimate authority that of what i
choose to feel that i believe in and
trust that has an internal locus of
control
but the information coming from without
in my own
internal processing of it are part of
the same
system so this is a perfect example of
what i was suggesting
up front where two people who do
whatever we're going to call this
will will have their own separate
glossaries
so if i can translate what you've just
said i daniel schmucktenberger
am not an independent thinker because
such a thing is inconceivable in human
form
right and i totally agree with that the
fact is not only
are you interwoven with all
sorts of humans who are responsible for
conveying to you in one way or another
conclusions that you couldn't possibly
check you know these are thoughts that
would be familiar
to descartes for example um
but you are also building from the
entirety
of cumulative human culture
right all of the tools with which you
can think
are uh almost all of them are too
ancient to even know
where their rudiments originated so
anyway i don't disagree with any of that
so to me i would say there is such a
thing as an independent thinker
and in your schema it has to do with
whether or not they are thinking a la
carte that is to say
using that set of tools that is most
effective irrespective of the fact that
those tools don't all come from
one tradition um and you would say there
is no
independent thought because a la carte
is the most you can do or something like
that
i might say that i like a term like
interdependent better because it doesn't
mean that there isn't an individual
involved but it means that the
individual without everyone else is also
not a thing
and so the recognition that
sovereignty and individuality is a thing
and it is conditioned by affected by and
affecting
other groups of people are both
necessary in the hegelian synthesis to
understand what is the nature of a human
are they fundamentally
individual and then groups emerge are
they fundamentally tribal and they're
formed by the tribe and it's very much
both in a kind of recursive process
between them
100 in fact i once wrote something i
called the declaration of
interdependence
it was a sort of proto-game b attempt to
define
what the rules of a functional society
would be like and i also frequently say
that the individual is more
an illusion than it is real and what i
describe is that an individual
is a level of understanding
that evolution has focused us on
because historically it has been sort of
the limit of that
where we might have some useful control
right
evolution might ultimately care about
whether or not you are
successful your genes are still around a
hundred generations from now
but your focus on a hundred generations
from now is unlikely to have any useful
impact whatsoever
whereas your focus on your life
and your children is likely to be useful
so
we have we have been delivered a kind of
temporal myopia in order to keep us
focused on that which
could be productive for an ancestor but
of course we are now living
in an era in which we can have dramatic
impacts
on the distant future in fact you and i
are both
quite focused on the strong possibility
that our
foolishness in the present will result
in
the end of our lineage and that that is
something
that evolution were it capable of um
upgrading would certainly have us
concerned about because the hazard is
very real
and our tendency not to think about it
is
a big part of the danger i think
temporal myopia and the
collective action collective
coordination problem is a good way to
describe all of the problems we face
or one of the generator functions of all
the problems we face that you have a
bunch of game theoretic situations where
each agent within their own agency
pursuing
the choice that makes most rational
sense to them pursues local optimums
where the collective body of that drives
local
global minimums but if anyone tries to
orient towards the longer term global
maximum they just lose in the short term
that's an arms race
that's a tragedy of the commons and so
how do we reorient the game theory
outside of those multipolar traps
i would say is one of our underlying
questions
that when the biggest harm we could
cause was mediated by stone tools or
bronze tools or iron tools or even
industrial tools we didn't have to cause
it immediately because the extent of
harm was limited in scope
when it is mediated by fully globalized
exponential tech
running up against planetary boundaries
with many different kinds of catastrophe
weapons held by many different agents
we actually have to solve the problem
yeah i
of course agree completely with this as
well that effectively
maybe it really is every single
important problem
is a collective action problem of one
kind or another
we've got races to the bottom we've got
tragedies of the commons we've got these
things
uh intermingled but once you start to
see that
on the one hand it is you could take
from it a kind of
reason for despair because these are not
easy problems to solve
on the other hand the discovery that
effectively it's not
a thousand distinct problems it's a
thousand variations on one theme
and that that theme is solvable in fact
we have for example
uh eleanor ostrom's work which points to
the fact that
evolution itself has solved these
problems many times
that that is hopeful so i don't know
where you are in terms of how hopeful
you find yourself about humanity's
future but i'm quite certain
that you and i will uh align
on the idea that yes if we could focus
on the problem as it was
it's more tractable than many people
think it is
yeah i mean you mentioned hopefulness
you mentioned a bunch of good things
there
that rather than a bunch of separate
problems you have
a few problems with lots of expressions
this was a big chunk of the kind of work
i engaged in and with a number of people
uh you were part of uh looking at
when we inventory across all of the
catastrophic and existential risks ones
involving
ai and problems with biotech and other
kind of exponential tech and
environmental mediated issues and things
that escalate to large-scale war
is there anything in terms of the
patterns of human behavior that they
have in common
and so this kind of race to the bottom
collective coordination
thing is one way of looking at that but
there's a there's a few ways of looking
at what we'd call the generator
functions of catastrophic risk
and it really is simplifying if you can
say are there categorical solutions
to those underlying generator functions
they're hard
right they're they're hard um now when
you talk about hopefulness
uh i notice that the way that i relate
to the optimism pessimism thing is
there's an optimism
which is almost like a choice to say
i'm going to have optimism that's that
there is a solution space worth
investigating even if i don't know what
it is
and if i'm wrong that's it's the right
side to be wrong on
as opposed to there was a solution i
didn't look for it um
and then i'm going to have pessimism
about my own solution so i'm going to
try to red team my solution so that i
can find out how they're going to fail
before
finding out how they fail the hard way
in the world but then
not be devastated by the fact and that
might that solution wasn't it and keep
trying and i think that's kind of how
the
um committedly inventive innovative
principle works
so uh yeah again we've we could uh do
almost a one-to-one mapping of your
schema onto mine
i do this in terms of prototyping rather
than
red teaming and discovering it's wrong
it amounts to the same thing
when you say actually it's hard you and
i would have to define
two different kinds of hard probably
there is
hard to make function to stabilize
and there's hard to figure out what the
solution is
and those are distinct we might find
elements of both of them here but
let me just give a maybe it's um
the canonical example of a solution to a
game theory problem
that uh everyone will recognize
i divide you choose right it's
the perfect solution to an obvious
problem
of choice and selfishness right
if there is cake and
i know that you're going to get your
choice and that you are incentivized to
pick the larger piece then i am
incentivized to get the cut as even as
possible
and the point is it neutralizes the
concern
so we are looking for solutions of that
nature
now i don't think they are
all that hard to understand in broad
terms in general it may
there may be a lot of work on the
discovery end but when you see them they
end up being surprisingly simple
my biggest fear is that the
there is it is very rare for people to
understand
how much danger we're in and
why and therefore what solution we are
inherently looking for
and um how urgently we should be seeking
it in other words as long as things
function pretty well
in the present and people get fed and
housed
it is very easy for them to ignore the
evidence that we are in grave danger
even if we are uh
fat and happy and uh enjoying a
you know a period of good luck
yeah when you like one of the
interesting things in the study of
previous
civilizations is that none of the great
civilizations of the past still exist
they all failed even if they had been
around for hundreds or thousands of
years
and so to to understand that
civilization's failing
is the only thing that's ever happened
and then recognize that
since world war ii we have for the first
time a fully globalized civilization
where none of the countries can make
their own stuff that the supply chains
that are necessary to make the
industrial and productive base are
globalized
and that we're running up against the
failure points of a globalized
civilization which
it that's an important thing and what's
so interesting is that all the previous
civilizations that failed
had so much hubris before their fall
because there had been so many
generations where they had succeeded
that they had forgotten that failing was
a thing it was just some ancient myth it
didn't feel real
so we don't have an intuition for things
not working or for catastrophe because
we haven't experienced it and
our parents didn't experience it and
it's only myth
and as a result we just make bad choices
and i mean this is where
studying history and studying
civilizational collapse is really
helpful
and you can see that even as the system
starts to fail in
partial ways um
you know to me it seems very clear that
when we look at the
george floyd protest turning into riots
over the summer that happened
they were following the covid shutdowns
and specifically all the unemployment
from it
when and whenever the unemployment goes
up whenever the homelessness goes up
when people can't when the society
makes it to where people who are trying
can't meet their basic needs then
it gets a lot easier to recognize
there's something wrong with the system
as a whole
and go against it but we also never had
a point in human history where
it was like no matter how outraged i am
all i have to do is start scrolling for
a second and i've forgotten everything
not to mention the fact that i'm
probably on opioids and benzos
and so that that makes it to where the
frog can keep boiling in hot water
longer
yeah so i i often say that people are
too comforted by
the idea that people are always
predicting the end of the world and it
hasn't happened yet because in fact it
happens all the time
right the ends of these civilizations
but it's even worse than the analysis
that you and i
appear to agree on here because many of
those civilizations
that have ended in fact most of them the
civilization
the organizational structure ended but
the people didn't
right so the romans
continued on as other things the maya
are still
with us right they are not with us as
the maya
and the point is actually in this case
the jeopardy that we are creating
is to our very capacity to continue
as a species not just to our ability to
continue with the structures
that we have built so not only are we
all in it together this time
but we're all in it in a way that we
never have been before or at least very
rarely have been before and that really
ought to have people's attention
but you're right the capacity to
distract ourselves from it
has never been better either
i think something that i find
particularly important when thinking
about
catastrophic risk now relative to
previous examples of civilization
collapse
is that until world war ii we couldn't
destroy everything
like we just didn't have enough
technological power for catastrophe
weapons
um and so you could fight the biggest
bloodiest war
violate all of the rules of war and it
would still be a local phenomena
and with the invention of the bomb we
had
now the new technological power to
actually
destroy habitability of the planet kind
of writ large or at least enough of it
that it was a
major catastrophic risk and on the time
scales
that you think about as an evolutionary
biologist of how long humans have been
here and the
you know proto-humans since world war ii
is no time at all to have really adapted
to understanding what the significance
of that is
and the only reason we made it through
was because we created an entire global
order to make sure we never used that
new piece of tech and in all of history
we always use the arms that we developed
and so we made this whole bretton woods
world and mutually assured destruction
that said okay well let's
have so much economic growth so rapidly
that nobody has to fight each other and
they can all have more because
the pie keeps getting bigger but that
starts running up against planetary
boundaries
and interconnecting the world so much it
gets so fragile that you know a virus
and wuhan shuts the whole world down
because of supply chain
you know interconnected supply chain
issues so that thing can't run forever
and the mutually assured destruction was
one catastrophe weapon and two
superpowers so mutually assured
destruction works the game theory of it
works
well as soon as you start to add to that
the bio weapons and the
chemical weapons the the fact that
bioweapons can be made very very cheaply
now with crisper gene drives and things
like that grown weapons
we have dozens of catastrophe weapons
held by many dozens of actors including
non-state actors
and that just keeps getting easier
mutually assured destruction can't be
put on that situation
it doesn't actually have a stable
equilibria
so now we have to say how do we deal
with
many many actors having many types of
catastrophe weapons
that can't have a forced game theoretic
solution
with a history where we always used our
power destructively at a certain point
how do we deal with that it's novel
right like we have no precedent for that
yeah it's absolutely novel i mean when i
became cognizant you know let's say 1975
is where i
first started having you know coherent
thoughts about
the world that was only 25 years after
the end of
world war ii and it seemed like world
war ii was a
very long time ago but of course we've
covered that distance twice since then
so the ability for you know that the
tools with which for us to self-destruct
as a result of aggression are brand new
and you're absolutely right the thing
that caused us from using them
or prevented us from using them that
force
disappeared it no longer exists there's
no steel stable equilibrium here so
what's protecting us is
not well understood at best and then add
to that
all of the various industrial
technologies that we are now
using at a scale where they imperil us
and i don't know about you but i keep
having the experience
of a catastrophe happens
and that's the point that i get alerted
to some process
that is very dangerous to humanity that
i didn't know about until the
catastrophe
right this has happened with the
financial collapse of 2008.
it happened with the triple meltdown at
fukushima
it happened at alizo canyon i believe it
has now happened
with covet 19 and gain a function
research
and the point is it paints a very clear
picture we
do things because we can't see why we
shouldn't or
this is also a game theory problem those
who can see why we shouldn't
don't and certain number of people don't
see why we shouldn't and they do
and we all suffer the consequence of
their myopia
and so on multiple fronts we are playing
you know we are rolling the dice year
after year
and the people who can think
independently looking at that
picture looking at the series of
accidents looking at the hazard of
something like a large-scale nuclear
exchange without an equilibrium to
prevent it
those people wake up but the problem is
the mechanism
to actually uh begin to steer
the ship in a reasonable direction in
light of these things
doesn't seem to exist for reasons i've
i've heard you explore many places so
what does it mean as far as you can tell
there's one thing that you said that i
think is worth us addressing first
is that some of the things that caused
the catastrophe either were unknown or
those who knew them were gained
theoretically less advantage than those
who were oriented on the opportunity
rather than the risk because those who
orient towards opportunity usually end
up amassing more resource that equals
more ability to keep moving stuff
through
there is a article and a conversation in
the less wrong community about
um regarding catastrophic risk mistake
theory versus conflict theory
what percentage of the of the issues
come from like
known stuff that we knew would cause a
problem or at least could cause a
problem
and game theoretically we went ahead
with it anyways versus stuff where we
just couldn't have anticipated or really
didn't anticipate
and i think it's fair to say these are
both issues right there's there's true
mistake theory stuff like we just
couldn't calculate
and then there's true conflict theory
stuff we knew that escalating this
military capacity would drive an arms
race where the other people would that
if we calculated it
there's an exponentiation on all arms
races that takes us to a very bad
long-term global situation one of the
insights that i think is
really interesting is that the the fact
that the mistake theory is a thing and
everyone acknowledges it
ends up being a cover a source of
plausible deniability for what's really
conflictary
so we we know there is an issue we
pretend not to know we do a [ __ ] job
of due diligence and risk analysis and
then afterwards say it was a failure of
imagination and we couldn't have
possibly
known i have actually been asked by
companies and organizations to do risk
analyses for them
where they did not want me to actually
show them the real risk they wanted me
to check a box
so they could say they did risk analysis
so they could pursue the opportunity
and when i started to show them the real
risk they're like [ __ ] we don't want to
know about that and so
when it comes to the could we have
possibly factored that
so i mean a classic example um i like to
give because it's so obvious
in retrospect is could we have known
in the development of the internal
combustion engine
that making street cars which seemed
like a very useful
upgrade of having the horse internalized
to the carriage
would end up causing climate change and
the petrodollar and wars over oil and
oil spills and mass and
ocean oil spills whatever it seems like
that would have been hard to know
a hundred years in the future that it
would do all that stuff
um and this is a classic example of also
where we solve a problem and end up
causing a worse problem down the road
in the nature of how we do it which you
can't keep doing forever
the story is oh we cause a worse problem
then that's the new
market opportunity to solve that problem
in the ongoing story of human innovation
but when you start running up against it
the problems are actually hitting
catastrophic points you don't get to
keep doing that ongoingly
you don't get to regulate after the fact
the way that we always have once a
problem
hits the world things that are
catastrophic um
could we have known well yeah in london
before that one there were already
electric motors
and two people were already getting sick
of burning coal
from uh lung disease from the burning of
the
hydrocarbons if we had tried to do good
risk analysis could we have
yeah but there's so much more incentive
on
who pursues the opportunity first and
then there's this multipolar trap of
well let's say we don't the other guy is
going to so it's going to get there
anyway so we might as well be the ones
to do it first
and that thing ends up getting us all
the time which is why collective action
again
comes in well it's really interesting
how much of this is again parallel
heather and i use the example of
somebody you know driving the first
internal combustion engine and somebody
chasing them down the street saying
don't do that you'll screw up the
atmosphere right how crazy is that
person running down the street saying
that because
you know you would have to scale it up
to such a degree
before that's even a concern that that
person seems like a nervous nelly but of
course they would also have been
prophetic
but the other thing i want to ask you
about is you say
that we have these two categories where
um sometimes we could have known and we
went
we we knew in fact and we went ahead
anyway
and then in other cases um
[Music]
we didn't know and something snuck up on
us and
i want to be i want to clarify what you
just said because my
understanding here is that if you dig
deep enough
somebody always knew right in general
there's some mechanism whereby the
person who correctly predicted what was
going to happen
has been silenced often they lose their
jobs they
disappear from polite society at the
point they turn out to be right their
reputations are never resurrected as far
as i can tell
so am i wrong that even in the cases
where
people who made the decisions may
plausibly have not known
that the reason they didn't know is
because there's some sort of active
process that when there's a process
a profit to be made shuts down anything
that could uh be the basis of a logical
argument that we shouldn't do it
i don't know that i'll say always i'll
i'll certainly say most of the time
um and let's say there was a case where
we
like really nobody knew
it's usual my guess is
we probably could have had we tried
harder
and then let's say there's going to be
some unpredictable stuff like we we know
in complex situations it's going to be
unpredictable stuff so you do the best
job you can
to forecast the risks and harms ahead of
time
but then you also have to be ongoingly
monitoring well what would the early
indicators that there's a problem be
and how do we take it when we find that
there's something we hadn't anticipated
how do we factor that into a change of
design well once
once the profit stream is going and the
change of design [ __ ] up the profit
stream
how does the recognition of that there's
a problem
actually get implemented when those who
have the choice implementation power are
not the people who are paying attention
to those indices so yes i would say
and it's easy to just say
hey yeah there was some there was some
whack-a-doodle who was saying that there
was going to be some rest but there's
always some wacky doodles thing there's
going to be risk about every new tech
and if we really listen to all them we'd
have no progress
that's the story right
it's a [ __ ] story could we
now let's there's but there's a
collective coordination issue
because it's it is fair to say so like
let's take um
ai weapons right now specifically uh
automated drone weapons there is an arms
race happening
on automated drone weapons and i think
every general and military strategist
knows that
all of our chants of dying
from ai weapons goes up their kids
everybody's
as we perc as we progress in that
technology it's a bad technology it
shouldn't exist
we should create an international
moratorium that says nobody builds ai
drone weapons
that we don't want automated weapons
with high intelligence out there
but we can't make that moratorium
because if one country doesn't agree
if one non-country some non-state actor
doesn't agree that has the technology
or let's say everybody agrees how do we
know they're not lying and developing it
as an underground black project
so either we don't even make the
agreement or we make the agreement
knowing we're gonna lie
defect in a black project spy on their
black project and try to lie to their
spies
who are spying on us and so it's like
how do you get around that thing
where if anyone does the bad thing in
the near term it confers so much game
theoretic advantage that anyone who
doesn't do it loses in the long term
why it was that the peaceful cultures
all got slaughtered by the warring
cultures and so what ends up making it
through is those who end up being
effective enough at war that's an
underlying thing we have to shift
because that has as its eventual
attractor space self-destruction in a
finite space
yeah i totally agree and the i think
fascinating thing when you
interact with the incarnate
aspect of the process you just described
is that the people
who are telling the lies
that explain why we're doing something
that we know is reckless
often don't know that that's what
they're doing right they actually
believe their own press and instead of
saying well
yes this is terrible but we don't really
have a choice
or somehow indicating that they know
that
what you encounter is a true believer
who thinks that this is safe
and that's very frightening because it
means that the mechanism at the point
something begins to go awry
to do anything about it doesn't exist
right or at least it's not connected to
the part that you can talk to
and um so again not
not too surprised to find um overlap in
our map
i would say the process that you
describe of
by the time you discover what the hazard
is that there's a
profit that has uh accelerated the
process
i call this the senescence of
civilization because it's actually
exactly a mirror
for the process that causes a body to
senesce the evolution of senescence
involves
processes that have two aspects one
which benefits you when you're young
and another which harms you when you're
old and because many
individuals don't live long enough to
experience the harms
in old age they get away with it from
evolution's point of view
and evolution favors the trait in spite
of the late life harm so
those late life harms accumulate and
that's the reason that we grow feeble
with age and die and that's an exact
mirror
for the way we've set up our economic
and political system
where any process that is profitable in
the short term
at the res at the consequence of having
some dire
implication for civilization later on
those processes are so
ingrained by the time we discover what
the harm looks like in its full
form there's nothing we can do to stop
them okay so let's use
two really important current examples
so let's take facebook and social media
and
the way they've affected the information
commons and the epistemic commons are at
large
so we know that the nature of the
algorithms optimizing for time on site
while being able to factor
what i pay attention to the whole
tristan hair story
makes almost it very few people wake up
and say i'd like to spend six hours on
facebook
and so i'm gonna spend more time on
facebook
if i kind of leave executive function
rational brain and get into
some kind of limbicly hijacked state
where i forget that i don't want to
spend my whole day on facebook
and so time on site maximization appeals
to existing bias and appeals to limbic
hijacks
so if i piss off and scare the whole and
and elicit sexual desire and whatever of
the whole population while doubling down
on their bias
and creating stronger in-group
identities
associated without group identities the
algorithms optimize well it
is an ai of the power that beats cast
private chess
beating us at the nature of the control
of our attention
so we can see that the right got more
right the left got more left
the conspiracy theories got wackier the
anti-conspiracy
theory people became more
uh upset at the idea that a conspiracy
could ever exist
basically everybody's bias doubles down
and they all move apart from each other
faster
well society doesn't get to keep working
that that is a democracy killer right
that's an open society killer
there's a reason china controlled its
internet is if you don't want
your society to die you have to be able
to have some shared basis of thought
so we can say and the story is oh we
didn't know that was going to happen
well you go back and look and guys like
jaren lanier
were at the very beginning of facebook
and google whatever saying hey guys this
ad model is going to [ __ ] everything up
like you can't do the ad model thing you
got to have paid for subscription or
you know some other kind of thing and i
was like shut up dude
um and or just don't even engage in the
conversation and then get to say
afterwards failure of imagination but
now
how do you regulate it when those
corporations are more powerful than
countries
because some the regulation is going to
be happen in a court where the lobbyists
have to be paid for by somebody
right so who are the lobbyists paid for
by and it has to be supported by popular
attention and those who can
control everybody's attention can also
affect what is
in popular attention so this is a very
real example where we know the harms
were known
and and it actually got large enough
that it killed the regulatory
apparatuses capacity
absolutely um in fact again this is
going to be another
alignment of our maps so what i've been
playing with is the idea
that we are incorrect in imagining that
people
necessarily want their uh
their expectations flattered that people
actually may like to be challenged
but that it's inconsistent with the
well-being of advertisers that the very
fact is
because advertising is only a tiny
fraction informative and is mostly
manipulative you have to be in your
unconscious autopilot phase
in order for it to cause you to buy a
car you wouldn't have otherwise bought
or buy different deodorant than you
would otherwise
buy and so the point is in order for us
to be the thing gets paid for by
advertising
in order to be useful to advertisers we
have to be unconscious and the only way
to keep us unconscious is not to
challenge us basically to tell us what
we think we already know rather than
what we need to know
and so they're lulling us into this even
though we would
still be interested in the platforms if
we weren't being advertised to but we
would be interested in having
more important conversations there which
is really in some sense what
the the growth of heterodox podcast
space is about
oh my goodness okay there's two
directions i want to go at the same time
i'll just pick one
there's a reward circuit on exercise and
there's a reward circuit on junk food
right and they both have a dopaminergic
element and reward circuit but
of a very different kind and the reward
circuit on exercise
is that it actually feels like [ __ ] at
first and
it's hard and but your baseline
uh of happiness measured in whatever
dopamine opioid access whatever gets
better over time
and then you start actually feeling over
time but not quickly this is another
place where
um temporal myopia ends up mattering
because there's a delayed causation on
the healthy one and no delayed causation
on the unhealthy one
so i start getting the reward circuit on
exercise when i start seeing results
and then i want to push hard and then
i'm willing to actually go against
entropy and put energy into the system
so the energy grows whereas the
chocolate cake i get a reward
instantly and i don't have to apply any
energy but as i do it my baseline gets
worse and this is the like addiction
versus health reward circuit direction
and the same is true for scrolling
facebook compared to reading an
educational book
at the end of a month of reading the
educational books my life feels better i
feel more proud of myself
at the end of a month of scrolling
facebook i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
doing with my life
and and yet that one will keep winning
for the same reason that
70 of our population is overweight and
over a third of them obese
and so but not
but my only hope is that not everyone
who has access to too many calories is
obese
right like there are some people who
figured out hey that's a reward circuit
i don't want
to do and i'm going to exercise and i'm
going to not eat all of the fat sugar
salt that evolution program me to have a
dopamine hit for because
it's a shitty direction now we need to
get that number of people who actually
have taken
some sovereignty over their fitness and
well-being in the presence of the
cheaper reward circuit
we need to get that number up to
everybody because right now obviously
overweight is one of the main causes of
death in the developed world but we have
to then apply that to the even more
pernicious
hypernormal stimuli because salt fat
sugar or hypernormal stimuli on
in the augustatory system right we have
to apply that to
the sensory system that's coming in
through things like social media
and that means less social media less
entertainment more study
and it doesn't have as fast a reward
circuit it just doesn't but it has a
much better longer term reward circuit
where your baseline goes up and this is
where
enough mindfulness and enough discipline
have to come in
because otherwise the orientation of the
system is that it's more profitable
for corporations for me to be addicted
because you maximize lifetime value of a
customer
through addiction and it's an asymmetric
war because they're a billionaire
trillion dollar company and i'm me
so how do i win in that asymmetric war
where it's in their profit incentive
whether it's mcdonald's or
facebook or fox for me to be maximally
addicted
i have to recognize holy [ __ ] right like
i actually have no sovereignty even if i
claim to live in a democracy against
hypocrisy who want to control and
manipulate my behavior in a way that is
net negative for me
holistically while having the plausible
deniability that i'm choosing it because
they're coercing my choice
so i have to get afraid of that enough
that i mount a rebellion right a
revolutionary war in myself
against those who want to drive my hyper
normal stimulus reward circuit so
the whole how can everybody become more
immune
to the shitty reward circuits and notice
them and become immune to them
and how can they become more oriented to
the healthy reward circuits that's
another way of talking about what we
have to do writ large
yeah that's beautiful i completely
agree um in fact it dovetails with
another
thought that uh first time i thought it
i thought it was original and then
having said it i discovered lots and
lots of people had said it before me
um that there's a very close
relationship between
wisdom and delayed gratification that
it's the ability to bypass the
short-term
reward circuit in order to get to
something uh deeper and better
um that is you know that is what wisdom
is about
but you didn't include on your list what
i consider to be
maybe the one of the most important
instances
of the failure that you're talking about
which is sex
there's a very direct comparison at
least for
either males who are wired uh
in a normal fashion for a straight guy
or women who are toying with that same
programming which i believe there are
many
but the comparison between casual
sex which is certainly
we are as males wired to find that
a very appealing notion because it's
such a bargain if you can produce a baby
where you're not expected to contribute
to its raising that's a that's a huge
evolutionary win
um and then you have to compare that to
the rewards of a deep romantic
lasting relationship with commitment and
the problem is
that the deep lasting relationship stuff
has a hard time winning out
over the instant gratification thing if
the instant gratification thing is at
all common
and uh so that's really screwing up
people's circuitry with respect to
interpersonal
relationships and bonding and i have a
sense that it is also in a way that's
much harder to demonstrate
contributing to the derangement of
civilization that people
many fewer people have a relationship
you know it's not like uh marriage is
easy
right it's not it's super complex but
having somebody who you can fully trust
somebody who you've effectively
you know fused your identity with to the
level
that they share your interests and uh
you know they may be the only person
who'll tell you what you need to know at
some points and the fact that many
people are missing that i think is
uh deeply unhealthy
yeah so i would say that
market type dynamics
benefit from exploiting the shitty
reward circuits across
every evolved reward circuit axis
and so from an evolutionary point of
view survive and mate are the things
that make your genes get through
primarily so we mentioned the
survive the calorie one early earlier
right so
in an evolutionary environment i could
get plenty of green leafy things
in many environments um it was very hard
to get enough fat
enough sugar and enough salt those were
evolutionarily rare
things so more dopaminergic hits on
those so
fast food ended up figuring out how to
just combine fat salt sugar with no
other nutrients with maximized
uh ease of palatability and textures
and there's like a scientific
optimization of all of the dopamine hit
with none of the nutrients so you can
actually be obese and dying of
starvation
right and what that is to nutrition
where you would should have a natural
dopaminergic kid on something that has
nutrients built in for
you know adaptive purposes is what porn
and online dating
is to intimate relationship is
what facebook and instagram is to tribal
bonding
is how do we take the hyper normal
stimuli
part of it out separate it from the
nutrients and
make a maximally fast addictive hit that
actually
has none of what requires energetic
process
yeah i've called this the junkification
of everything and it is
directly an allusion to junk food where
we can most easily see this but the idea
is you will be given
a distilled so if i can rephrase what
you said
in terms that are more native to me
when you are wired to seek
you know the umami
taste that tends to be very tightly
correlated with meat
you will tend to get a lot of nutrients
along with it
in in the ancestral context in the
modern context we can figure out how to
just
trip the circuit that tells you to be
rewarded and it's no longer a proxy for
the things that it was supposed to lead
you to
and as you just said you can now look at
that across
every domain where you have these
dopamine rewards
and understand why people are you know
living in the world
that pinker correctly identifies we are
living in
where we have just a huge abundance and
yet
are so darn unhealthy certainly
unsatisfied
right it explains that that paradox of
being better off in many ways than any
ancestor
could have hoped to be and yet being
effectively ill across every domain
yeah i will say something about this
that's
important i mean briefly the fact that
life expectancy started going down in
the last five years
in the us and certain parts of the
developed world is really important to
pay attention to
but the deeper point i want to make is
the hubsyan view on the past
i think is one of those like mistake
theory information theory
things um i mean mistake theory conflict
theory
i think the dialectic of progress is
such a compelling idea
and we're oriented to the opportunity
and not the risk in the same way we
don't want to look at the risk moving
forward that would
have us avoid an opportunity we don't
want to look at good things in the past
and we don't want to look at good things
of cultures that we want to obliterate
so we want to call the native american
savages so that we can of course
emancipate them
uh historically and we want this
hobbesian view that people had brutish
nasty mean short-lived lives in the past
so that we don't have to face the fact
that advanced civilizations failed
and that is what our own future most
likely portends i think
um i think that is a convenient wrong
belief system in a similar way
well i hope you don't hear me doing that
i certainly don't you don't i just i had
to say it
you have to say it so it's clear to to
our our listeners well
i appreciate you doing that um i did
want to go back to a couple things you
said and
you know of course this happens every
time you and i talk where every
every thread you know takes on multiple
possible directions we could go and
there's no way to cover them all
but in any case you pointed to survival
and mating being the primary mechanisms
to get your genes into the future
and i want to point out that this is one
of these places where
our wiring which is biased in the
direction of
those places where our ancestors had
agency that was meaningful
up upends us and in fact this is
something i think you and i are
struggling against as we try to compel
people of the kind of danger we're in
and the necessity to upgrade our system
you know before we run into a
catastrophe too big to come back from
and so in any case
within your population survival and
mating
makes sense as an obsession but probably
the biggest
factor in whether or not your genes are
around 100 generations from now
is whether the population that you were
a part of persists
and so you know my field has done a
terrible job with this
we have gotten pretty good at thinking
about individual
level adaptation and fitness and you
know when i say
lineage people still don't know what i'm
talking about and they're
i'm confused about why i'm focused on it
and my sense is it's like
two components to an equation and
you know you're either aware of the
lineage thing but you misunderstand it
as group selection or you're not aware
of the lineage thing and you think group
selection is a fiction and it's all
about individuals and you know both of
those are ways to misunderstand
um the point i'm so happy to hear you
saying this because
uh i'm sure this is a conversation i
would love to go deeper and understand
the the distinctions between lineage and
group selection the way that you see
them
but if i just even take the concept of
group selection as opposed to just
individual selection and
take a species like sapiens and say
there was no such thing as an individual
that got selected for that was not an
effective part of a group of people
and the tribe the band was the thing
that was being selected for
so there was a fundamentally kind of
pro-social behavior that were
requisite um but then
we get bigger than the dunbar number
only like yesterday
evolutionarily and
that whole the whole evolutionary
dynamics break
because that pro-social behavior only
worked up to that scale
when everybody could see everybody and
knew everything right like there's
when we start looking at how do we solve
collective action problems
you start realizing well how do if we
make some agreement field as to how
nobody
does the near-term game theoretically
advantageous relative to each other
long-term bad thing there has to be
transparency mechanisms to notice it
so the beginning of defecting on the
whole defecting on the law the agreement
field the
morals is the ability to hide stuff and
get away with it
well you can't hide stuff in a tiny
tribe very well
even even if you can do it once twice 10
times
sooner or later if hyde is your instinct
you'll be revealed and the cost will
exceed what you've
built up by uh by pulling it off however
many times you've done it
and so there's a forced transparency in
that
smallness of evolutionary scale and
when you start to get up to a large
scale and now there have to be systems
where everybody isn't seeing everyone
and i'm smart enough i can figure out
how to play it and
[ __ ] the whole while pretending that i'm
not hiding the accounting of it and
getting ahead
that's the evolutionary niche for
corruption for parasitic behavior so one
way i would describe
and as you've described down here before
if there's a niche with some energy in
it it's going to get exploited right
um we have to rigorously
close the evolutionary niches for human
parasitic behavior
humans parasitizing other humans and the
first part of that
is a kind of forced transparency that if
someone were to engage in that it has to
be known
and now the question is that's all the
versions of that we've explored
at scale look like dreadful surveillance
states
so how do you make something that
doesn't look like a dreadful
surveillance state
that also doesn't leave evolutionary
niches for parasitic behavior that ends
up rewarding and
incenting sociopathy absolutely
so a bunch of different threads one
the eleanor ostrom work is important
because it does
point to the fact that you can scale
these mechanisms up in fact selection
has scaled up these enforcement
mechanisms beyond
a tiny number of people who know each
other
intimately now it hasn't scaled them way
up but it's proof of concept
in terms of the ability to get there and
it's a
model of what these systems might
look like the other thing though your
your focus on corruption i think is
absolutely
right and one way
to just detect how stark the difference
is
is the recognition of how many times in
an average day
you encounter [ __ ]
right in other words how many
advertisements do you encounter
in an average precovet day let's say
right these are all cases where somebody
you don't know
or almost all of them are cases where
somebody you don't know
is attempting to manipulate you into
spending resources differently than you
would otherwise
spend them so this is an overwhelmingly
dishonest
interaction with your world and there
would have been some dishonesty
for an ancient ancestor you know
obviously there are
uh creatures that attempt to look like
what they are not but in general
one could see the world as it was
and the deception was the exception not
the rule
and in some sense uh we
live in a sea
of [ __ ] right and we're so used to
it that we don't even recognize that
that's
abnormal that it is the um the result of
a gigantic niche that has opened up as a
simple matter of scale
as you point out uh and that
um restoring a state where you can
actually
trust your senses you can by and large
trust the people
who you're interacting with to inform
you rather than lie to you
um would be a huge step towards uh
reasonability
oh i really hope that we follow all the
threads here
because this is getting so close to the
heart of
what we have to do
as scale increases the potential for
asymmetry increases
and as the asymmetry increases the
asymmetric warfare
gets more difficult to deal with
so let's think about this in terms of
market theory
let's think about an early
hypothetical idealized market like
literally people just took their
shoes and their cows and their sheep and
their service offerings to a market and
they
looked at exchanging them and then
because trading
cows for chickens is hard we have some
kind of currency to mediate a barter
of goods and services but we're talking
about real goods and services
maybe there's two people maybe there's
five people that sell shoes there's not
five
thousand of them and i can go touch the
shoes myself i can talk with them i can
see what the price is
and there is no hyper normal stimuli of
advertising it's like somebody yelling
from his thing
so there's a symmetry between the supply
and the demand side
right the supply side is a guy or a few
guys selling something and the demand
side is a person or a family trying to
buy something and they can kind of tell
each other's [ __ ]
to some degree of symmetry buy or beware
becomes an important idea
but now when this becomes nike and then
still one person there's still a
symmetry between supply and demand in
aggregate meaning the total amount
of money flowing into supply equals the
total amount flowing out of demand but
this side
is coordinated and this side isn't you
don't have something like a labor union
on all purchasers
where it's like all facebook users are
part of some union that puts money
together to counter facebook and
lobbying and regulation you have
facebook as like up close to a trillion
dollar organization against
me as a person and i'm still the same
size person that i was in those early
market examples but there wasn't like a
trillion dollar organization
and now when that happens manufactured
demand
kills market theory and classical market
theory
which is the the idea of why
a market is like evolution right it's
like some
evolutionary process is that the demand
is based on
real people wanting things that will
actually enhance the quality of their
life
and so that creates an evolutionary
niche for people to provide supply
and then the rational actor will
purchase
the good or service at the best price
and of the best value
but of course as soon as we get to a
situation where
and you look at dan orioli and all the
behavioral economics saying the the
homo economicus the rational actor
doesn't exist we end up making choices
based on
status that's conferred with a brand
based on
uh the compellingness of the marketing
based on all kinds of things that are
not
the best product or service of the best
price
but you also get that i want stuff that
will not increase the quality of my life
i desperately want [ __ ] because i was
there the demand was manufactured into
me so it's not an
emergent authentic demand that
represents collective intelligence
it's a supply side saying i want to get
them to want more of my [ __ ]
and i actually have the power to do that
using
applied psychology like actual and as
soon as you get to split testing
and the ability to ai split test a
gazillion things
we're talking about radically
scientifically optimized psychological
manipulation
for the supply side to create artificial
demand
and then be able to fulfill it and
and most of that ends up being of the
type that is actually bad for the
quality of the life of the people but
you have the plausible deniability
they're choosing it hey i don't want to
be patriarchal and
control what they're doing the people
are choosing it i'm just
offering the source of supply that
they're wanting [ __ ] that's like
offering crack to kids and then when
they come back for more of it like
saying hey
so this is that was one of the threads i
wanted to address
well i love it um back in uh
must have been 2013 when game b was
actually
a group of people who met in a room and
talked about things
one of the points that i um was making
in that context
was this inherent asymmetry around
unionization
and that the problem is unions have
gotten a bad rap
because of the tight association
cognitively that we have with labor
unions right we think of unions and
labor unions as synonymous but union is
actually
a category it's potentially a very large
category and effectively
management always has the benefit of it
the question is
will workers have a symmetrical entity
right that's the labor case but you can
make the same case
with respect to you know banking credit
unions don't work they're very bank-like
but if they were structured in such a
way to actually
you know unionize people who utilize the
bank
could be highly effective could be a
complete replacement for the insurance
industry which doesn't even make sense
in a market context
but as a risk pool you could do a very
effective job so anyway yes
the the question is how do you scale up
the
uh collective force and especially how
do you do it in light of the fact
that the entities that are already
effectively unionized
see it coming and they disrupt it with
all of their very powerful
tools and so um
well anyway go ahead i want to say the
beginning of an answer to
that because i think it brings us to
what you've been largely exploring in
the show of late of the breakdown of
democracy and open society and what do
we do about that and how that relates to
breakdown in culture and breakdown and
market we can look at those
the relationship between those three
types of entities
so
a way of thinking about what the
architectural
idea of a liberal democracy is
and why say the founders of this country
set it up not as a pure laissez-faire
market but as a as a state
that had regulatory power and the market
together
was the idea is that a market will
provision
lots of goods and services better than a
centralized
government will so let's leave the
market to do the kind of provisioning of
resource and innovation that it does
well
but the market will also do a couple
really bad things it will lead to
increasing asymmetries of wealth
inexorably this is what piketty's data
showed and but it's just obvious having
more money
increases your capacity to have access
to financial services and you know you
you make interest on debt and on um
compounding interest on wealth
and so you end up getting a power law
distribution of wealth
so then a few people in just the market
dynamic would be able to have way
outsized control over everyone else
against everyone else's interests and
the market creates opportunities for
things that are really bad we all
know that like we want there to be a
thing called crime where you don't
where even though there's a market
incentive for child sex trafficking and
whatever else we say
no we're we're going to create some rule
of law that binds that thing and not
just have market
drive it so the idea is
that we create a state that we actually
give a monopoly of violence to so it has
even more power at the bottom of the
stack of what power is than the top of
the economic power law distribution
so the wealthiest people and the
wealthiest corporations will still be
bound by this rule of law
and the rule of law is an encoding of
the collective
ethics of the people right the ethics
are the basis of
jurisprudence and there is some kind of
democratic process of getting to say
what is it that we consider the good
life and important that we want
enshrined in rule of law
we give that a monopoly of violence and
really then the goal of the state
is to bind the predatory aspects of
market incentive while leaving the
market to do the things that it does
well
but pretty much every law is where
someone has an incentive to do something
which is a market type dynamic
that is bad for the whole enough that we
make a lot to bind it
okay so the purpose of a state is to
bind the predatory aspects of a market
that only works as long as the people
bind the state
and the people behind the state if you
have a government of
for and by the people of an educated
populist who are
who had a quality of education that were
capable of understanding all the issues
upon
which we are governing and making law
and
a fourth estate where the news that they
are getting is of adequate quality and
unbiased enough that they're informed
about what's currently happening
for if you think about that that's what
a republic would require
and you realize that both public
education and the fourth estate have
eroded
so badly for so long it's not that we're
close to losing our democracy
it it's dead we don't have a republic we
have a permanent
political class in a permanent economic
lobbying class
and the people who aren't really
actively engaged in government in
any way at all beyond maybe jury duty
now and again if they can't get out of
it
and if the people to be engaged in
government in any meaningful way had to
tell the doe what they think should be
done about grid security and energy
policy
or tell the dod what should be done
about nuclear first strike policy or
tell the fed and treasury what they
think about interest rates
they don't they have no [ __ ] idea how
to have a governance of formed by the
people
they don't have that education they
don't have uh
the media basis so if the culture
if the people can't check the state then
the state
will end up getting captured by the
market and so you'll end up having
the head of the fda be someone who ran a
big drug or a big
ag company and the head of the dod being
somebody who ran lockheed or some
military
industrial complex manufacturer you'll
have just lobbying just straightforward
lobbying gets paid for by somebody who's
they get paid for those who have the
money to pay for lots of lobbyists
and so then you end up getting a crony
capitalist structure which is worse than
just an evil market
because now it has the regulatory
apparatus of rule of law and monopoly of
violence backing up
the market type the dynamics
so then we say okay well what do we do
here
and we see that civilizations fail
towards either oppression or chaos
right those are the two failed states
they fail towards oppression
if trying to create some coherence
happens through a top-down forcing
function
they fail towards chaos if not having
enough top-down forcing function
everybody
kind of believes whatever they want but
they have no unifying basis for belief
and so then
they will end up going into they'll
they'll balkanize they'll tribalize and
then the tribal groups will fight
against each other
if you don't want to so and so either
we keep failing towards chaos which we
can see is happening in the west and in
the us in particular right now
and then china which is happy to do the
oppression thing and oppression beats
chaos and war
right because it has more ability to
execute effectively which is why
china has built high-speed trains all
around the world when we haven't built a
single one in our country
um so either we lose to china in the
21st century and oppression runs the
21st century or we beat china at being
china meaning beated an oppression or
it's like [ __ ] those are both failure
modes
what is the what is there other than
oppression or
um or chaos is
order that is emergent not imposed which
requires a culture of people who can all
make sense of the world on their own and
communicate effectively to have shared
sense making
as a basis for shared choice making the
idea of an open society
is that some huge number of people can
all make choices together a huge number
of people
who see the world differently and are
anonymous to each other not a tribe
that was an enlightenment era idea right
born out of the idea that we could all
make sense of the world together born
out of the philosophy of science and the
hegelian dialectic that we could make
sense of
base reality and that we could make
sense of each other's perspective
dialectic find a synthesis and then be
able to have that be the basis of
governance
so what what i think is this is not an
adequate long-term structure because we
can talk about why tech has made
nation-state democracies
obsolete and it's just not obvious yet
but it has but as an intermediate
structure the reboot of the thing that
was intended has to start at the level
of the people at culture
and that collective sense making and
collective good faith dialogue
because without that you can't find
state without that you can't find market
incentive
okay i love this riff of yours okay i
think there's a tremendous
amount that's really important and the
synthesis is super tight
i know people will have a little bit of
trouble following it but i
i actually would advise them to maybe to
go back through it and listen to it
again because it's
right on the money as far as i'm
concerned there's one place where i
wonder if it doesn't have two things
inverted so you talk about the two
characteristics that are necessary
in order for uh what did you call it
liberal democracy or
whatever it was that you used as a
moniker to function
one of them had to do with the idea that
the state was big enough to bind the
most
powerful and well-resourced actors
and the second was that the people have
to be capable of binding the state
now i understood you to say that what
failed first
was the people's ability to bind the
state is that
correct
i'm saying that's at the foundation of
the stack that we have to address
the failure with recursive so
as i see it what happened was
the power the fact that there is always
corruption
it's impossible to drive it out
completely the corruption self enlarges
the loopholes
and becomes subtle enough that it's hard
to see directly
the most powerful actors suddenly got an
infusion
of power and we could trace down the
cause of it but let's just say somewhere
in
recent history the most powerful actors
became more powerful than the state and
what they did with that power
was they unhooked the ability of the
state to regulate the market
i believe the reason for this was that
each
individual
industry had an interest in having its
regulations removed in order to create a
bigger slice of the pie for it
and so effectively what you had was each
industry agreeing to unregulate every
other industry
like you can unregulate if i have a
pharmaceutical company
right and you're an oil company and
you want to make money but you have to
be able to [ __ ] up the atmosphere to do
it
and i want to make money giving people
drugs that they shouldn't have
um and you know corrupting the the fda
then we'll partner and see what you got
was many industries partnering to unhook
the ability of the state to bind
the market but one of the things that
they had to do in order to make that
work
was they had to eliminate the ability of
the people to veto
right and so this is where we get this
incredibly toxic duopoly
that pretends to do our bidding and
pretends to be
um you know fiercely opposed the two
sides of it but in fact the
thing they're united about is not
allowing something else to compete with
them
for power so it's you know the wolf in
sheep's clothing
is in charge of the thing that is
supposed to be
protecting us from wolves um in any case
we don't have to go
too deep there but this this is actually
super important
go for it this is related to the thing
we said about
as the market as a whole gets bigger
then the individual consumer stays an
individual consumer but the supply side
the company gets much larger
as that happens the asymmetry of the war
between them of the game theory between
them
gets larger and so uh manufactured
demand becomes a more intense thing well
the same thing is true
in terms of the market capacity to
influence the government and the market
government complex's capacity
to keep the population from getting in
the way
of the extraction and so
there's a heap of mechanisms that happen
and there's not like five guys at the
top who are coordinating all this it's a
shared attractor or incentive landscape
that orients it
yeah largely emergent yeah and where
there are people conspiring it's because
their shared incentive and capacity to
do so
which so the conspiracy is itself an
emergent property of the incentive
dynamics which then in turn doubles down
on the types of incentive dynamics that
make things like that succeed
so okay let's take a couple examples
if people haven't read it they should
all read at least the wikipedia page on
public choice theory a school of
libertarian thought that critiques why
representative democracy will always
break down that
the founders of the us basically said
this
um which is
all right we'll come back to cemetery
for a moment at the time
that we were creating this structure of
liberal democracy the size
of choices and the speed of them
was smaller and slower such that the
town hall was a real thing
and when the town hall is a real thing
the coupling between the representative
and the people is
way higher right because the people are
actually picking representatives in real
time that are really representing their
interests and they get to have
a say in it there was a a statement by
one of the founders of the country that
uh voting is the death of democracy
because the idea is we should just be
able to have a conversation that is good
enough that we come up with a solution
and everyone's like that's a good idea
if we can't then we vote but that means
that some
big percentage close to half the
population feels unhappy with the thing
that happened
and so it's a sublimated type of warfare
it's a sublimation of violence but that
leads to a polarization of the
population
and so the goal is not voting voting is
the last step of when we couldn't just
succeed at a better conversation and
specking out
what is the problem what are the
adjacent problems what are the
design constraints of a good solution
can we come up with a solution that
meets everybody's design constraints as
best as possible
okay so i disagree with this at one
level as i'm sure
you will as well i'm not sure but i
suspect but i love
something about the formulation that
voting is itself
a kind of failure mode right that
ideally speaking if you had a well-oiled
machine if you had a uh
you know a military is the wrong analogy
here but
let's say you had a you know a ship of
people
fighting impossible odds to
make it back to safe harbor right the
point is you really shouldn't
want a system in which you're voting
between two
different approaches to the problem you
should
want a discussion in which everybody by
the end is on board
and if you try to do that in
civilization we'd never accomplish
anything right you effectively have to
give
the majority the ability to exert a kind
of tyranny over the minority in order to
accomplish the
most basic stuff but that's because the
system is incapable of doing what a
better system would do
which is to say this is the compelling
answer and you're going to know why by
the time we decide to do it
wait there's a cemetery here between the
conversation that we had about
the market in sending people who focus
on the opportunity and not the risk
such that it actually suppresses those
who look at the risk
once you say hey there's always going to
be somebody talking about a risk that
isn't going to happen we'll innovate our
way out and that becomes the story now
you have plausible deniability to always
do that
once you say there's no way to get
everybody on the same page we can't do
that it'd be too slow
now i don't even have any basis to try
right and so i don't ever even try to
say what is it that
everyone cares about relative to this so
i even know what a good solution would
look like to craft a proposal no
we're going to vote on the proposition
having never done any sense making about
what a good proposition would be
and that's just mind-blowingly stupid
right and so then who's going to craft
the proposition a lawyer lawyer is paid
for by who some special interest group
and so now so
most of the time what happens is
you have some situation where one thing
that matters to some people has this
proposition put forward that benefits it
simply in the short term but it
externalizes a harm to something that
matters to other people
but ultimately all of it matters to
everybody just differentially weighted
and the how do we put all those things
together so
okay we're going to do something that's
going to benefit the economy but harm
the environment
well everybody cares about the economy
and everybody cares about the
environment
but if i put forward a proposition that
says in order to solve climate change
we have to agree to these carbon
emission controls that china won't agree
to and therefore china will run the
world in the 21st century and we all
have to learn
mandarin or be like the wigar or
something okay well now i have a bunch
of people who
because they hate the solution space
because it harm something else they care
about
don't believe in climate change it has
nothing to do with not believing in
climate change not caring about the
environment
it's that they care about that other
risk so much as well but if i said okay
well let's look at
it's a negotiation tactic is what you're
saying that at the point
that you want x prioritized over y
you'll potentially you'll descend into a
state in which you'll make
any argument that results in that
happening including why doesn't exist
exactly because i'm so motivated by this
other thing
and the solution has a has a
theory of trade-offs built in that is
not necessary sometimes the theory of
trade-off is necessary but oftentimes
a synergistic satisfier could be found
but we didn't try
in the same way that a way to move
forward with the opportunity without the
risk could have happened we could have
found a better way to do the tech that
internalized that externality
we just need to try a little bit more
but there isn't the incentive to do it
so let's say we said
no we don't care about climate change by
itself
we care about the climate and we care
about the economy and we care about
energy independence and we care about
geopolitics
and we're going to look at the adjacent
things we're making a choice in one of
the areas
necessarily affects the other area and
we're going to bring those design
constraints together and we say what is
the best choice that affects these
things together
then we could start to think about a
proposition intelligently
we don't do this in medicine either we
make a medicine to solve
a very narrow definition of one
molecular target of a disease that
externalizes side effects in other areas
without addressing upstream what was
actually causing the disease
and then the side effects of that med
end up being another med and then old
people die on 20 meds
of iatrogenic disease so in complex
systems you can't separate the problems
that way
you have to think about the whole
complex thing better and so
so the first part of fixing one part of
fixing democracy that we have to think
about
is we have to define the problem spaces
better more complex
and we have to be able to actually have
a process for coming up with
propositions that are not stupid and
intrinsically polarizing
because almost no proposition ever voted
on gets 90
of the vote it gets 51 [ __ ] percent
of the vote which means
half of the people think it's terrible
and so what that means is you care about
the environment i care about the economy
on proposition a
well you petition to get the thing to go
through
because you care about the owls there
but i think that you're making my kids
poor you're my [ __ ] enemy now and
i'll fight against you now
all the energy goes into internal
friction fighting against each other
and any other country that's willing to
be autocratic and force all their people
onto one side will just win
and we will increasingly polarize
against each other over something where
we could have found a more unifying
solution
now this is fascinating for one thing
you blazed by it there but
i think so there's a place where jim
rutt
tells me that some place that you and
you and he
overwhelmingly agree also but there's a
place in which you and he have hung up
where he says that you believe that
a properly architected system can do
away with the trade-offs
right right i think i just heard you
give the answer that he must have
understood to be that
but wasn't it am i right that the answer
there are lots of times when you don't
see a trade-off
because you have two characteristics
both of which are sub-optimal and you
could improve them simultaneously and so
it looks like there's no trade-off
between them
if you push it far enough you'll
eventually reach the efficient frontier
where you do have to choose
but if you're not near the efficient
frontier there's no reason to treat it
as a trade-off
is that yes i'm not saying that we get
out of having constraints
i'm saying we can do design by
constraints
much better than we currently do and so
i'm saying that there's a lot of things
that we take as inexorable trade-offs
that aren't
well so you and i will have to chase
this down at some point my
argument will be any two desirable
characteristics have an inherent
trade-off between them
even if you never see it right there are
reasons you wouldn't see it
but that if you push these things far
enough you'll find that there are no
desirable things that can be components
of the same mechanism
that will not exhibit a trade-off
relationship
right
uh initially i don't agree with that at
all but i'm sure you've thought about it
a lot so i'm curious why you say it
well let me give you let me give you the
example i used to
battle my friend scott pakur
uh over with this which is he said why
can't you make a car
that's the fastest and the bluest
right and it you know the first time i
heard that i was like well
okay maybe blue is trivial enough but
it's not in fact
if you wanted to make a car that was the
fastest and by fastest let's say
fastest accelerating well you're going
to have to decide
how to paint it if you also decide that
there's some color of blue that is
bluest and you want the car to be that
color well then it has done a lot of the
choosing of what paint you're going to
put on it
at the point you decide to paint it that
color that paint will have components
that will weigh
something right the chances that the
bluest whatever you define that to be
is also the lightest and has the best
laminar flow characteristics are
essentially zero
right because they're an infinite
diversity of colors they will be made
out of a wide variety of materials
and the chances that the blue just
happens to be the one that is lightest
and has the best
you know slipperiness relative to the
wind are going to be
vanishingly small and that means that if
you want to make
truly the fastest car it's its color
will be chosen by whatever paint has the
best characteristics
and if you want to make it the bluest as
well you'll make some tiny compromise
that uh will you know probably not
matter to you but it's there so the
trade-off is there even if we don't see
it
but here's the thing daniel i discovered
many years after my argument with scott
was long since put to bed
that i was right about this and the way
i found out was that there is a
a case where the navy wanted to set the
time to climb
record for an aircraft and they took an
f-15 and they
souped it up a little bit and in order
to set the basically the vertical climb
rate of this aircraft
they stripped the paint off it and so if
you look at pictures of this aircraft
uh in its you know uh it's record
setting
run it isn't any particular color it's
many different colors because
effectively you've got the bare metal
underneath
with the paint stripped off it to save
however many pounds of paint they were
able to
remove okay there are three points that
come up
to um
address my initial thoughts on this here
so one is
with this particular case of a car
the difference between the
blue and the optimal color might be at
the boundary of measurement
itself yep and so while it's true that
there
it might not be a perfect optimum of
both at the level of
like a a nano scale optimization
it is irrelevant to the scale of choice
making for the most part
and when we look at something like 100
and when we look at something like tesla
cars
they became faster off the line than
ferraris and safer than volvo's and
greener than prius's at the same time
you could see that ground up design
just doing a better job of ground up
design was able to optimize for many
things simultaneously so
much better now had they made it less
comfortable could it be faster still
sure of course um so it's optimizing for
a product of a bunch of things together
but still in a whole different league
than
things had been previously now
first of all this this is beautiful okay
because this is exactly what i was
hoping for
okay um this is a question of us
tripping over each other's
language jim misunderstood what you were
saying
right and he asked me about it and i
said uh
yeah daniel can't be right about that if
he's saying what you think he's saying
but of course it wouldn't make sense
that you would think that you could so
your point about this being trivial
you're in complete agreement with me and
i suspect
it would take nothing to get jim to
agree to that formulation
as well wait there's a difference
there's one more thing i have to say
here
okay of course i'm not pretending that
thermodynamics don't exist
right and once you get down to the the
quantum scale arrangement of the thing
that orientation in one direction
doesn't have effects on
other things of duh yep
there's a difference also between
the blue and fast
are two different preferences
that are arbitrary that both want to be
associated with a car that don't have
some
um intrinsic unifying function and we
can say blue is a thing that's
reasonable to
be preferential about color
whereas i would say that there are some
characteristics that have a synergistic
effect that increasing one increases the
other one because of
the way they are part of a overall
increase in system integrity and so
synergy is the key concept i'm trying to
bring about here
which is behavioral systems more than
the sum of and unpredicted by the parts
taken separately
so when i say i'm looking for
synergistic satisfiers
the idea that i have x amount of input
and that input has to be divided between
these various types of output and
it's linear is nonsense i can have
i can have x amount of input and have
something where the total amount of
output has increased synergy based on
the
intelligence of the design the question
of how do we design in a way that is
optimizing synergy between all the
things that matter becomes the central
question
yes which is of course the central
question that selection must be dealing
with
in generating complex life
and you know i don't again i don't think
we have a hair's breadth
of difference on what we turn out to
believe
about this trade-off space but what i
would say is
and i don't want to drag the audience
too far down this road it's probably not
worth it for what we need to do here but
the benefit of being able to say so
let's take your example of there are
certain characteristics that will
co-maximize
not really because of the following
thing let's say that we figure out
what color is best for making
the fastest car and then we say well i
want to maximize
grade 37 and speed now i can do it i can
maximize gray 37 and speed because it
just so happens that gray 37 is the
color
that has the best characteristics for
speed right but then the point is you
can't separate these two things whatever
characteristic it is you're actually
maximizing
you've just found two aspects of it so
your point about synergy
is that perfectly aligned
characteristics
we could describe that joint that
fusion of those two things as one thing
and we could maximize
it right but then if we take the next
one over
right the next characteristic that we
want to add to the list of things then
again we're back in trade-off space so
my only point here is that there is a
value in order to be able to get the
maximum power out of
a trade-off theory what we want to do
is make it minimally complex and the
ability to say
every two desirable characteristics have
a trade-off between them
the real question is the slope or the
shape of the curve
right and that many of these slopes and
shapes mean we will see no meaningful
variation on it because
one side is a bargain and we will always
see that manifest
right that's the reason we don't see
trade-offs everywhere is that in some
cases
a trade-off is so dumb that we don't see
anybody exercising variation everything
has made the same decision
yes and i think for all
practical purposes we agree that being
able to make
a tesla that is safer than a volvo and
faster than a ferrari and greener than a
prius is a possibility and that we can
if we apply that to all of the problems
in the world we could do
a fuckton better job yeah i think we
also agree and i love the last point
that you made that to the degree that
two things can be simultaneously
optimized they can be thought of as
facets of a deeper
integrated thing yep
okay so now to answer the way that i
actually think about it
though this is irrelevant if people
disagree it doesn't matter at all to the
earlier point i have to
wax mystical a moment um when einstein
said
it's a optical delusion of consciousness
to believe there are separate things
there's in reality one thing we call
universe
uh and everything is a facet of it
if i look at the real things that we
have theory of trade-offs between in the
space in the social sphere and
the associated biosphere that we're a
part of
so let's say we talk about in the very
beginning of our conversation individual
what would optimize my individual
well-being and what would optimize the
individual
and what would optimize the well-being
of all humans i believe that i only find
that those are differently optimized
if i again take a very short-term focus
if i take a long-term focus i find that
they are one thing
because the idea that i'm an individual
and the idea that humanity is a separate
thing is actually a wrong idea they're
facets
of an integrated reality and that if i
factor all of the things that are in the
unknown unknown set over a long enough
period of time they're simultaneously
optimized and this is the essence of
dialectical thinking
is looking for the thesis and the
antithesis and not
voting between thesis and antithesis but
seeking synthesis that's at a higher
order of integration and complexity
totally agree and uh you know
so i i don't know how many people will
be tracking it but
you know effectively saying on a
indefinitely long
time scale these things converge is
an acknowledgement that we are not
talking about design space
when we make this recognition right it's
more like trajectory
and that is perfectly consistent
and frankly i think if everybody
understood
at some level the kind of picture we're
painting
people would be really comfortable with
the degree to which it doesn't do
exactly the thing they most hope it will
right in other words the level of
compromise is small
right what you which is why the
compromise in a healthy democracy even
was
tolerable even though that was nowhere
near as optimal a system systems we
could develop
okay there's a point a number of minutes
back that i want to return to
and i want to drop an idea on you it's
actually a place where something you
said caused me
to complete a thought that i've been
working on for some time
so the thought as it existed is
that markets are excellent at figuring
out
how to do things and they are atrocious
at telling us what to do
in other words they will find every
defect in human character and figure out
how to exploit it if you allow them to
do that
but when you have a problem that you
really want
solved right how can we make a phone
that doesn't require me to be plugged
into the wall allows me to get a message
across a distance to report an emergency
whatever
markets do a better job than we could
otherwise do of
figuring out what the best solution is
and so in some sense
the question is how can we structure the
incentives around the market so that
markets
only solve problems that we want them to
solve but they can be free to solve them
well and what
what i think i realized in this
conversation here
is that in some sense the role of the
citizenry
in a democracy is to discuss
the values that we want government to
deploy
incentives around in other words the
people by deciding
what their priorities are what their
concerns are
which problems are top of the list to be
solved and which ones
could take a back seat that that's the
proper
thing that we are to be discussing that
the role of government freed from
corruption
would be to figure out what incentives
will result
in the best return on our investment
structuring the incentives of the market
and then the market can be freed
to solve the narrowest problems on that
list
and i think we fail at every level here
but from the point of view of what we're
actually shooting for
i would say it's somewhere in that
neighborhood that division of labor
between the citizens the apparatus of
governance
and the market
i'm suffering a little bit here because
there's like 10 simultaneous threads
that i really
could address that are important and i
know we're going to open up more in
starting
i it would be really fun to go through
the transcript of this and come back to
the most important threads
might be worth doing actually so
first i want to say something against
heterodox market theory is i don't think
the market is the best system
for innovation of a known what
um and i think uh
world war ii and the manhattan project
is a very clear example in the apollo
project
and our on our failure at fusion i would
say that
the point you're about to make to me
fusion would be our top priority because
it's the only plug-and-play
solution to a large piece of our problem
and the fact that we decade after decade
are awaiting a
proper fusion solution says you know
despite the fact that the market could
potentially solve it the problem is the
investments are too large on the front
end and
the reward is too delayed for the market
to actually even
recognize the problem correctly venture
capital is not going to put up the
amount of money that a nation's day can
for the amount of time that's necessary
and
when you look at the very largest jumps
in innovative capacity a lot of them
happen by nation state funding not
market funding and then
a market emerging in association with
kind of government contracting
and so if we like if we look at why the
nazis were so technologically farther
ahead than everyone else going into
world war ii
with the enigma machine in the beginning
of computing with the v2 rocket
it was not a market dynamic it was a
state dynamic where they invested
in science and technology development
for a long time which is why this tiny
little country with limited industrial
supply capacity had more technological
advancement than the
soviets or the us and it was
it was our ability to steal their [ __ ]
and rip it off and then be bigger than
them that was a big part of how we were
able to
succeed in the war effort and so
that's a clear example that like
computers were developed by a state not
the market
right hold on a second i want to be
careful because i don't want to falsify
something that isn't false i again think
this is a place where our mappings
uh or at least the language surrounding
them is going to upend us
because this sounds like a place where
a government is capable of generating a
massive
incentive to cause a problem to be
solved that the market won't even find
on its own
right so that does not strike me as
inconsistent with what i was just saying
the state
recognizes there's a problem creates an
incentive big enough
to find the solution and that incentive
can be
uh big enough to cause people to get
different degrees than they would
otherwise
seek and uh but in these cases it wasn't
like so let's take the manhattan project
it wasn't private contractors
that solved it because the government
had made the incentive it was actually
government that solved it it was
government employees and so this is a
this important distinction
nasa was not a private space contracting
thing that did
the apollo project it was a government
project so
i would say the largest jumps we ever
made in tech
did not happen in the market for the
most part
well so then i guess the test of
your falsification here is the following
question
if the manhattan project
had consisted of a state yanking people
out of their beds
and standing over them with rifles
would it have worked i mean maybe you
know the russian
version is closer to that um
but i i think the point is you still
have
a you have a system of incentives
correctly solving a problem that the
market would not have found on its own
and no entity in the market would have
been big enough to solve
so i still see it as consistent
but you might you might convince me
otherwise especially if it turns out
that
a negative incentive would be just as
effective
at creating the solution
there's a there's a story
that people don't innovate well under
duress
the innovation requires executive
function and prefrontal function and if
they're too limbically oriented they
won't innovate well which is one of the
reasons why we need an open society
and i think there's probably some truth
to this but less truth than we would
hope
i believe it was called the sharashka
system which was a
russian uh
basically prisoner of war type camps
that had scientists that were doing real
innovation
up to you know early sputnik-like work
so we know that people under rifled
arrest can innovate
we know that people conscripted by draft
into
an army can actually innovate on behalf
of the military
now i think that it's true
that something more like a market will
explore more edge cases that are not
known once and come up with interesting
things
whereas the centralized thing can do a
better job
sometimes of existing watts that require
very high
coordination because if you look at the
manhattan project the scale of the
budget and the scale of coordination
no company has that and a bunch of
companies competing for intellectual
property and whatever it wouldn't have
worked
right right one of the reasons i bring
this up is because there's a whole bunch
you mentioned fusion whether it's fusion
or whether it's
um thorium or whether it's
closer to room temperature
superconduction or any of the things it
could possibly generate whether it's 65
percent efficient
photovoltaic through nanotech there's a
bunch of things
where we're like we kind of know the
science that could lead to the
breakthrough but the level of investment
just isn't there
um and i think there's a heap of
examples like this where
the percentage of the budget of the
national budget that used to go to r d
has went down a lot and it shouldn't and
the apollo project was kind of the last
thing
of its type and then the government
starting to shift to government
contractors started to be a source of
massive bloat
where the government contractors had an
incentive to just charge whatever the
[ __ ] they wanted
which is why then elon could beat
lockheed and boeing at rockets
so much cost-wise because then in that
situation
he didn't have to do the fundamental
innovation on rocketry he could just out
compete them with market incentive
and then that could create enough money
for iterative
innovation i think fundamental
innovation of
certain scales does require larger
coordination than markets make easy
okay so then i want to modify what i
said because you've convinced me
i didn't have it right in the initial
one so the
the point then is you have to extend
the governmental structure so that it
can deal
with two types of market failure one
surrounding
the natural system of incentives which
will cause you to innovate things that
do
net harm for example and the other is a
failure
where the scale of the market is not
sufficient to solve certain problems
that are
in our collective interest to solve yes
and we don't want to give the government
that much power because we don't trust
that kind of authority
but that's because the people aren't
checking the government which comes back
to the thing that we talked about
earlier
and now this becomes one of the central
questions of the time is
what is the basis of legitimate
authority and how do we know and what is
the basis of warranted trust
because we all know what it means to
have trust that isn't warranted we
everyone who disagrees with us we think
that their trust isn't warranted right
like
if if we're on the left we think people
who believe in who trust trump it's
unwarranted and
they think that the people who trust
the fda or vaccine scientists or the cdc
have trust it's unwarranted
we also know that legitimate authority
the idea of legitimate authority is so
powerful to be able to be the arbiters
of what is true and what is real
that anyone who is playing the game of
power has a maximum incentive however
successful they are to be able to
capture and influence that for their
good we also know that it's possible to
mislead with
with exclusively true facts
that are cherry picked or framed so i
can i can cherry pick facts on one side
or the other side of a gaussian
distribution and tell any story i want
that will make it through a fact checker
so fact checking is valuable but not
even close to sufficient
um so i can lie through
something like the atlantic as well as i
can lie through something like breitbart
through different mechanisms
for different populations yeah this this
is a super excellent point as well
that a fact checker
airs in one direction and if you can
build a falsehood
out of true objects that have been
edited
um then the fact checker won't spot it
so love that point
and so i can
do a safety analysis on a drug
and i'm not looking at every metric that
matters i'm looking at some subset of
the metrics and it might be that it's
safe on those metrics but in
but all-cause mortality increases life
expectancy decreases but i only did the
safety study for two years
so i wouldn't notice that so i can say
no methodologically this was perfect and
sound it all just also doesn't matter
because it wasn't i wasn't measuring the
right things
right and so this also uh
basically what you have just said means
that the replication crisis
can be understood as a mechanism for
generating
data which can be cherry picked to reach
any conclusion you want about the
effects of
this intervention or that intervention
right because effectively what you have
is the ability to choose between
experiments where sampling error will
result
in uh both outcomes being
evident somewhere this is another one of
those
is it conflict theory or information or
mistake theory thing
is i can intentionally
manipulate an outcome that looks
methodologically sound
and then say oh we just didn't know
those factors right
i'm not saying that whether that's
happening or not it certainly can happen
okay so now we get back to so what is
the how do you have a legitimate
authority that has the power of being
the arbiter of what is true and real and
all the power that's associated and have
it not get captured by power interests
is a very very important question how in
the name of
the bible and christendom and jesus
saying let he who has no sins cast the
first stone did we do the inquisition
right like weird mental gymnastics by
which the
authority of that thing was able to be
used for the power purposes of the time
and so now when you start to have
increasing polarization between the left
and the right and historically more
academics being left leaning and the
social scientists
the social sciences being so complex
that you can cherry pick whatever the
[ __ ] you want and do methodologically
sound and yet still misrepresentative
stuff
then you say is that actually
a trustworthy source and then we say
okay well do we want a bunch of wacky
theories going out over facebook and
twitter and whatever do we want to
censor it well if we censor it
who is the arbiter of truth that we
trust if we don't censor it
we're appealing to the worst aspects of
everyone and making them all worse in
all directions like those
both suck so bad and that's the
oppression or chaos right
and the only answer out of the
oppression or chaos is the comprehensive
education of everyone
in the capacity to understand at least
three things
they have to increase their first person
second person and third person
epistemics
their third person epistemics is the
easiest philosophy of science formal
logic
their ability to actually make sense of
base reality through
appropriate methodology and find
appropriate confidence margin
second person is my ability to make
sense of your perspective can i steal
man where you're coming from can i
inhabit your position
well and if i'm not oriented to do that
then i'm not going to find the synthesis
of a dialectic i'm going to be arguing
for one side of partiality
harming something that will actually
harm the thing i care about in the long
run
and then first person can i notice my
own biases
and my own susceptibilities and my own
group identity issues and whatever well
enough that those aren't the things that
run me
when i look at kind of the ancient greek
enlightenment
the first person was the stoic tradition
the
second person was the socratic tradition
the third person was the aristotelian
tradition
there's a mirror of all those in
modernity we need a new cultural
enlightenment now
that where everyone values good sense
making about themselves about others
about base reality
and good quality dialogue with other
people that are also sense making to
emerge to a collective consciousness and
collective intelligence it is more than
our individual
intelligence and with so that we have
some basis of something that isn't chaos
but that also isn't depression because
it's emergent more than imposed
so it's like it's cultural enlightenment
or bust as far as i'm concerned
all right so i don't disagree with you
fundamentally i believe this is a place
where
when i say my version of this which is
much less sophisticated in some ways and
focused elsewhere
but when i say my version of it i lose
people
because my version of it is something
like
[Music]
what we need to do is doable
we can see the trajectory from here you
can't see
the objective but you can see the
direction to head
and it will take three generations
to get there right
i agree what you're describing you
couldn't just simply take that
curriculum
and infuse it into any system we've got
and have any hope
of people learning it or give a [ __ ]
giving a [ __ ] about it or
whatever it wouldn't work so you have to
build the scaffolding that would allow
a population to be
enlightened in this way such that the
governance structure you're imagining
might arise out of it could flourish
but let's put it this way it's at least
at least three generations
out before you had gotten there even if
you started doing things right now
and so what i try to say to people in
order that they
don't completely lose interest in the
possibility of a solution because it's
too far out
is things can start getting better right
away
we are not going to live to be in that
world
that is the objective and even if we did
we would never be native there
right our developmental
trajectory will have been completed in a
world that doesn't function like that
and so
you know you you can be happy as an
expat but we would be expats in the
world we're trying to create
and that's fine you know if our
grandchildren or our great grandchildren
were native there and we could be expats
there
that that would be a perfectly
acceptable solution but
i think in general people have the sense
that a solution
sounds like something that we could have
in the next few
years and i just don't see the
possibility of it
no you're going to see things anything
that can be implemented
quickly you want a red team and say
either how does it fail or where does it
externalize harm
and also what arms race does it drive of
whoever doesn't like it
and if you factor what arms race it
drives where it externalizes harm and
where it fails
you'll get much less optimistic about
most of those things and if you don't go
into despair you'll start
thinking long term and things that
converge in long-term direction and when
you start to think about
that the thesis and the antithesis are
both not true
they have partial truth but they are not
actually true synthesis
is in the direction of more integration
of truth and still not true but in the
direction of
if i optimize for one of these
it will externalize harm in a way that
messes the whole thing up
right and that's why there's there's a
forcing function of the failure modes on
both sides that's why it's important to
look at oppression and chaos and say
these both create failure modes
so what is it that doesn't orient in
either those directions it's not more
power to authorities
it's not more pure libertarianism it's
something that's
outside of that access or it is going to
involve
the equivalent of negative feedback
right in other words right thermostat
works by virtue of not embracing it
being hot or
cold but by pushing it in the right
direction as it diverts one way or the
other
so i very much like your point about
synthesis here
just to make it clearer synthesis is two
things even
linguistically speaking we can talk of a
synthesis
right which is an object you could write
it in a book a
synthesis between several different
concepts could exist in
a book incidentally that's sort of what
i see myself
doing in biology is synthesis um
but your point is the most important
aspect of synthesis
is it is a process right and so that
process
is the thing that takes these competing
failure modes and rescues from them
something that uh suffers neither
consequence and
heads towards optimality so i
agree we have to get yeah so synthesis
is an ongoing process
and let's say i have some
bits of true information and a thesis
and some bits in the
antithesis so the synthesis will have
more bits in either of them higher order
complexity but it will still have
radically less bits
of information than all of reality about
that thing the model is never the thing
right
it's just it's the best epistemically we
can do at that moment
so now i want to go back to the earlier
topic around theory of trade-offs that
you said because
i i let it go but as soon as you mention
optimization i have to bring it back
because it comes back exactly here
and it also brings back this question
you had of that
markets can do a good job with the what
with the how but not the what which is
the is odd distinction that comes up in
science right yes it is
science can do a good job of what is but
not what ought
which means applied science i.e
technology i.e markets can do a good job
with make with changing is
but not in the direction of ought and so
that is ethics which is to be the basis
of jurisprudence and law that's
exactly why you bring those things
together
the and it's because is
is measurable third person measurable
and verifiable repeatable it's objective
it's objective right whereas ought
is not measurable in a you can do
something like sam harris doesn't moral
landscape and say it relates to
measurable things but it doesn't relate
to a finite number of measurable things
there's a girdle proof
that whatever finite number there are
some other things that we end up finding
later that are also relevant to the
thing that weren't part of the model
that
we were looking at and so
um the thing that is worth
optimizing for you talked about
the blue and the fast would be part of
the same thing the thing that is worth
optimizing for is not measurable
it includes measurables but it is not
limited to a finite set of measurables
that you can run optimization theory and
have an ai optimize everything for us
yeah i agree you will have a long
list of characteristics that you can
measure
and as you go from the most important to
the least important you'll eventually
drop below some threshold of noise where
you're not noticing things that
contribute
so yes it you've got a potentially
infinite set of things that matter less
and less
and you will inherently concentrate on
the biggest most important contributors
up top
and that's natural it's it's a it's an
issue of precision
at some level but one that we we
shouldn't convince ourselves
that we're um solving the puzzle
completely at a mathematical level
an engineering solution is not a
complete mathematical solution
right okay so now i'm come back to the
waxing mystical thing
and it's i don't think it has to be
thought of that way
um i don't i think the way einstein was
doing it he says spinoza's god is my god
i'm happy to do it that way
so the first verse of the tao dei ching
is the dao that is speakable is not the
eternal dao
right the optimization function that is
optimizable with a narrow ai is not the
thing to optimize for is a is a
corollary statement and
and the jewish commandment about no
false idols
is that the model of reality is never
reality so take the model
as this is useful it's not an absolute
truth the moment i take it as it's an
absolute truth
and i become some weird fundamentalist
who stops learning
who stops being open to new input and in
optimizing the model
where the model is different than
reality i can harm reality
and then defend the model so i always
want to hold the model with
this is the best we currently have and
in the future we'll see that it's wrong
and we want to see that it's wrong we
don't want to defend it against its own
evolution
and so what we're optimizing for
can't be fully explicated and that's
what wisdom is
wisdom is the difference between the
optimization function and the right
choice
oh i love this this is uh this is great
obviously
it dovetails with the basic sense of
what metaphorical truth
is and the recognition that actually
metaphorical truth isn't something that
applies
to religious style beliefs it's actually
the way we do science also
you know we have approximations and you
know things get ugly when people forget
that that's what they're dealing with
right and they start really treating it
as the object itself
a very important example in my field
is the instantiation of the term fitness
right which in most cases has so much to
do
with reproductive success that we
actually just synonymize them most of
the time and we speak as if they're
interchangeable
which is great except for all those
cases where they go in opposite
directions which we are perennially
confused by
and so anyway sooner or later i will
deliver some work that will take the
cases that we can't sort out because
we've misdefined fitness and forgotten
that it was a model in the first place
and shows how you would solve it
differently if you defined fitness in a
in a tighter way but uh story for
another day
all right so where should we go you uh
you were on a roll
so you'll see
conversations from really smart people
like nick bostrom and max tegmark and
whatever of
because of the collective action problem
and the multi-polar trap race to the
bottom
and yet because of the complexity of the
issues that we face
that are beyond what the smartest person
could
manage by a lot is the only answer
to build a benevolent ai overlord that
can run a one world
government because it can process the
information to make good choices
so as you can guess my answer is
vigorously no
yep not just because i think the
optimization function that it would run
no matter how many variables would end
up becoming a paperclip maximizer
but uh i think its own existential risks
are bound up
in that process these guys know know
this
but it's easy to pick solutions like
that compared to the other ones that
seem
maybe even more likely to go terrible
so then we say okay we don't want
a one world government run by
any of the people we currently have and
we also don't want separate nations
where any of them that defect lead
everybody into a race to the bottom
so that means that they have to have
rule of law over each other because they
affect common spaces
so how do you have rule of law over each
other without it being one world
government and then capture
oppression or chaos at various scales
and the only answer is the comprehensive
education enlightenment of the people
that can
check those systems now obviously the
founding of this country was fraught
with all the problems that we know of
now in particular
and it was still a step forward in terms
of
a movement towards the possibility of
some freedoms from the feudalism it came
from
and so i i find the study
of the foundation of it the theoretical
foundation of it meaningful to what
we're doing right now
and famously there's this quote from
george washington where he says
something to the effect i'm going to
paraphrase it the comprehensive
education of every single citizen in the
science of government should be the main
aim
of the federal government and i think it
is fascinating
so science of government was his term of
art and science of government meant
everything that you would need to have a
government of formed by the people which
is the
history the social philosophy the the
game theory in political science and
economics as well as the science to
understand the infrastructural tech
stack and whatever right
um the hegelian dialectic the
enlightenment ideas of the time
but the number one goal of the federal
government is not
rule of law and it's not
currency creation and it's not
protection of its borders because if
it's any of those things it will become
an oppressive tyranny soon
it has to be the comprehensive education
of the people if it is to be a
government of formed by the people now
this is the interesting thing
now i remember where i want to go
comprehensive education of the people is
a
force is is something that makes more
cemetery possible
symmetry of power possible it's a
increasing
people's information access and
processing is a
um symmetry increasing function
so everyone who has a vested interest in
increasing asymmetries
has an interest in decreasing people's
comprehensive education in the science
of government
and so now let's look at the education
changes that happened following world
war ii in the us
there is a theory there's a there's a
story that i buy
that the u.s started
focusing on stem education science
technology engineering math
super heavily partly because it was an
existential risk because look what
happened with the stem
that the germans did and now we know
that a lot of the german scientists that
we didn't get in operation paperclip the
russians got and sputnik and so
it's an existential risk to not dominate
the tech space so we need to really
double down on stem and we need
all the smartest guys we need to find
every von neumann and touring
and finding there is so the smarter you
are the more you want to push you into
stem so you can be an effective
part of the system that's part of the
story
but also the thing that washington said
the education and the science of
government we started cutting civics
radically
and i think it was because social
philosophers at the time like marx were
actually problematic to the dominant
system
and i'm not saying that mark's got the
right ideas i'm saying
the idea of okay we have a system where
let's have the only people who really
think about
social philosophy be the children of
elites who go to private schools
who learn the classics and otherwise
let's have people not [ __ ] the system up
as a whole but be very useful to the
system by becoming good at stem i think
this is a way of being able to
simultaneously advance education
and [ __ ] the kind of education that
would be necessary
to have a self-governing system that's
fascinating that's fascinating because
of course if you
have the elites effectively in charge
of governance they can do
exactly what you would imagine the
elites would hope for
which is to govern well enough that the
system
continues on no matter what but to
continue to look out for
the distribution of wealth and power and
make sure nothing upends it
right they'll do it they won't even
realize necessarily that that's what
they're doing
i also love the fact you know george
washington is one of these characters
who it's very easy to misunderstand
how good he was because you know he
wasn't the most articulate
founder or in you know classical terms
the
the smartest founder by far on the other
hand
an awful lot of wisdom buried in in
george washington
and uh this idea of
you know ultimately he was looking very
deeply into the future potentially to
understand
why the education of the populace
would be effectively synonymous with the
job
of government and it's not because the
purpose is the education but it's
because that's the only hope that a
democratic system
will spit out the kind of solution that
you want it to generate
which is uh i don't know it's a very
it's a very interesting
analysis so it it raises something else
here which is on my
list of notes arising which is i noticed
this pattern all over the place
there's a state which is awesome
very powerful in terms of what it can do
but it's fragile
and so it falls apart right in other
words we will never have a better system
as far as i can tell than science for
figuring out what's true
and what is possible so it's the most
capable state there are measures by
which it is the strongest
state but it is also terrifically
susceptible
to market forces in fact it can't be in
the same room with them
right so we could look for many examples
of this where something marvelous
requires a very
careful arrangement of conditions in
order for it to survive
and i'm wondering what you make of that
in light of this discussion
i guess it's not hard to make an
argument for why
that those two things go together
capacity and fragility
but what are we to do about it going
forward because surely we're trying to
build these states but do so in a robust
form
they go together because of synergy
which is
you have properties that none of your
cells on their own have you as a whole
there's a synergy of those cells coming
together that creates emergent
properties at the level of you as a
whole thing
but if i run all the combinatorial
possibilities of a way of putting those
50 to 100 trillion cells together
very few of them produce the synergy of
you there's most of them are just piles
of goo
yeah right and so it's a
it's a very narrow set of things that
actually has the very high synergies and
it's
lots of things that are pretty entropic
um and entropy is also
obviously easier i can i can take this
house down in five minutes with a
wrecker ball but it took a year to build
yup and i can kill an adult in a second
but it takes 20 years to grow one
so this is why the first ethic of
hippocrates and of so many ethnic
systems is first do no harm
then try to make [ __ ] better but first
do no harm if you if you can succeed
at the maintenance function then you can
actually maintain your progress
functions
and
[Music]
come back to where you were going with
that well so here's
here's what i'm after i agree with your
basic entropic analysis
that it is easier to destroy than to
build the
number of states that work is vastly
exceeded by the
organization of the same pieces that
don't
but what i'm wondering about is is there
in effect one has to be able to build a
system
that is resistant to that in other words
and life does this right
living creatures manage to fend off
entropy
beautifully and the
fact we need a
governmental structure that has that
same trick and we haven't seen it yet
and the question is unfortunately i
fear that
it is almost a prerequisite that if you
build the com
the capable structure and you haven't
built the thing that protects it first
then it will be captured before the
wisdom develops
to preserve it against that force
and now i remember where i used the
analogy of the body
what i'm going to say here is wrong so
let's just take it as a loose metaphor
let's take in the body that the closest
thing to
top down organization is neuroendocrine
system
but there's a bunch of bottom up that is
at the level of genetics
and and epigenetics and cellular
dynamics and whatever and there is a
relationship between the bottom-up and
top-down dynamics
well obviously i can take a cell out of
a body and put it in addition it has its
own
internal um homeodynamic processes it's
dealing with entropy on its own
they don't need a top-down
neuroendocrine signal for how they do
that so
let's say we tried to make a perfect
top-down neuroendocrine system
and the cells had no cellular immune
systems or redox
signaling uh homeodynamics or or
anything else
you would die so quickly right there is
no way to have a healthy body at the
level of the organization of all the
cells if the cells are all unhealthy
and that's the comprehensive education
of the individual thing we're talking
about can you make
a healthy system of government as a
system can you just get the cybernetics
right
with that is separate then that which
develops
all of the individuals and the
relationships between them and the
answer is definitely not
okay agreed but then here's the problem
that i'm
i'm trying to articulate
okay so we agree that the cells have to
be coherent in an
of themselves that there has to be a
fractal aspect
to this uh this organization of things
across
many scales from the individual up to
the the body politic
but if it is true that the key to making
that work is that
individuals which are analogous to cells
here
have to be educated in the nature of
governance the theory of governance in
order for this to work
how would they end up that way well they
would end up that way because governance
will have created the conditions that
would cause that education
so are we not now saying that what is
necessary in order for the system to
function
is that the system is already functional
in order that it can generate the
conditions necessary
no there's no hole in the bucket
situation there is a recursive situation
between bottom up and top-down dynamics
and so let's take
the classic dialectic that relates to
right and left it's not the only one
of individual and collective for a
moment and
say okay fundamentally the right
is more libertarian individual pull
yourself up by your bootstraps we want
to
have advantage conferred to those that
are actually doing
uh they're conferring their own
advantage
and doing well and then
the left model the more socialist model
is
yeah but people who are born into
wealthy areas statistically do better
than people who are born into shitty
areas in terms of crime and education
and access to early health care and
nutrition and all those things
and you can't libertarianly hold
yourself up by your bootstraps as a
infant or a fetus and so let's
make a system that tends to that well
but then the right would say but we
don't want something like a welfare
state that makes shitty people that just
meets their needs for them and orients
them to
lay on the couch all day and do tv and
crack okay
i think it's i think it's
mind-bogglingly silly that we take these
as if they are in
a fundamental theory of trade-offs as
opposed to a recursive relationship that
can be on a virtuous cycle
what we want to optimize for is the
virtuous cycle
between the individuals and the society
so that do we want to create social
systems that take care of individuals
but make shittier people
no do we want to create social systems
that condition people that have
more uh effectiveness and sovereignty
and autonomy yes and do we want to
condition ones that in turn
add to the quality of society yes so
if we don't want to make dumb social
systems right
so a social system that is more
welfare-like is much dumber than a
social system that provides much better
health care and education
and orientation towards opportunity for
advancement
rather than towards opportunity towards
addiction cul-de-sacs and so
we already have some people all the
listeners of your show i think we
already have some people who are trying
to educate themselves independent of not
having a government that is doing that
that and this is why i say it has to
start at culture before
state or market it has to boot in that
direction
so those people can start to work
together to say how do we influence the
state
and to start to then influence better
education for more people better media
and news for more people and how do we
influence it to affect market dynamics
where the market dynamics are more bound
to the society
well-being as a whole rather than
extractive i like this because
we actually do see this dynamic we see
people
actually seeking out nuance even though
we're told that they won't do it
and so the other thing we're seeing is
for various reasons including
covid the absurdity of the educational
system that we have is being
revealed in a way that it never has been
before so many more people are
recognizing
that school will flat out waste your
time if you give it that opportunity
and therefore they have more license
than ever to seek out
uh high quality insight and
exercises or whatever and to discount
the value that we are assured
comes along with a standard degree
etc so yeah i'm i'm
favorable to this idea also that you
just said that's interesting is
okay so george washington's quote
comprehensive education of every citizen
science of government well how can we
afford that when most of them are going
to be laborers
because them having a strong background
in
in history and in political science and
social science and the infrastructural
tech stack does that help them be better
farmers not really
it helps them be better citizens and
government but not better farmers
and so can how do we afford to pay for
all that additional education
and how do they maintain that knowledge
when they're just engaged in a
labor-type dynamic
and so this is why the children of the
elite who are actually going to become
lobbyists and senators and whatever go
to that private school and get that
education
well now we have this ai and robotic
technological unemployment
issue coming up and it's definitely
coming up right well the things that it
will be
obsoleting first are the things that
take the least unique human capabilities
because those are the easiest to
automate so labor type things
so either this is an apocalypse that
just increases wealth inequality and
everybody's homeless and [ __ ]
or on the absolute minimum amount of
basic income so the elites can keep
running the
robots as serfs rather than the people
of serfs and just hook the people up to
oculus
with a basic income so they don't get in
the way
or this actually makes
possible a much higher education of
everyone so they can be engaged in
higher
level types of activities um
yeah yeah now i agree with that
completely and i also agree
you know we should make sure people
understand
i mean i think it was very clear the way
you said it but we are headed for a
circumstance
in which a shift in the way the market
functions and what it requires
is going to cause an awful lot of people
to be surplus to it all at the same time
and that can only play out in a few ways
none of them are good if we don't see it
coming
and plan for it it's coming it's not the
fault of the people
who will be obsoleted um and so
in any case yes uh this
makes sense you mentioned you look at
covet and you look at how many small
businesses shut down
and how much unemployment happened and
then how much the market rallied because
six companies made all of the money of
the market and if you take those
companies out the entire stock market is
down but it's cap weighted
and you basically have network dynamics
metcalf law dynamics creating winner
take all
economies where you have one winner per
vertical
the wealth consolidation the wealth
inequality has progressed so
rapidly that all the that
the measurements of gdp and market
success and the measurements of quality
of life are totally decoupled they're
moving in opposite
directions in really important ways when
you combine
how intense that is and that of course
the forces with the most money are the
hardest to regulate because they have
the best lawyers and the ability for
offshore accounts and for lobbying and
whatever else
so how do you do anything about this
combined with the fact that the debt to
gdp ratio is unfixable
you realize that a reset of our systems
will happen because this system cannot
continue
and we can either do a proactive one or
we get the reactive one
and the reactive one worse the reactive
one
is going to inherently be uh
arbitrary and therefore much more
violent in every
sense of that term and so yes you are
programming some kind of
a uh unfortunately none of the terms
that one would like
are still available to us because great
reset is obviously
been branded in in somebody's interest
but
um yes we need some sort of a reboot uh
that takes um
heed of this dynamic and sets us on a
path where it doesn't turn into a
catastrophe or it doesn't turn into
a spectacular win at everybody else's
expense for
some party or other and
unfortunately of course if we circle
back to
an early part of this discussion
convincing
people of the hazard of this the
essentially the certainty that something
of this sort uh will happen if we do
nothing
that we must do something that that
something must be coordinated that you
can't pass it through
your inherited lens of is this left
leaning is this right leaning is this
for my team is this against my team
convincing people of that is extremely
difficult in this environment
because for one thing everything we
would do to convince
passes through these these platforms
that if they haven't flexed their muscle
yet
as soon as we start talking about what
would need to be done to save
civilization
in ways that they can recognize it they
will find ways to oppose it
and you've had this conversation
on here before that
let's say we can we look at a particular
group and we can predict how they're
going to respond to something we're
going to say with quite high accuracy
so we can take a particular woke sjw
group and
if we have a conversation of a certain
type we can predict that they'll say
oh that thing you're calling dialectic
is giving platform to racists when you
should be canceling them therefore
you're
you know uh racist by association or
whatever you can take
a q anon group and predict
that they are going to say that because
we talked to someone that was four steps
away from epstein in a
network that we are probably part of the
deep state cabal of pedophiles or
whatever it is
and um to the degree that people
have responses that can be predicted
better than a gpt-3 algorithm
they can't really be considered a
general intelligence
they are just a medic propagator they
are taking in memes
rejecting the ones that don't fit with
the meme complex taking in the ones that
do fit and then propagating them
and i think people should i think if
people think about that
they should feel badly about not being
someone who's actually thinking on their
own
and being a highly predictable memetic
propagator
and be like i would like to have
thoughts that are not
more predictable than a gpt3 algorithm i
would like to know what my own thoughts
about this are
and in order to know what my own
thoughts about it are do i can i even
understand and inhabit
how other people think all the things
that they think
that so that's that's one thing because
it's not only going through the filters
like facebook it's going through the
filters of the fact that people have
these memetic complexes that keep them
from thinking
and so the cultural value of trying to
understand other people so that we can
compromise
because politics is a way to sublimate
warfare
right and if you don't understand each
other and compromise you get war
and the people who are saying yes let's
bring on the war they're just [ __ ]
dumb they just don't
understand what war is actually like
they haven't been in it right
um
well i think you have brought us to the
perfect last
topic here now of course i'd like this
conversation to go on and we should pick
it up at another date but
the point you make about if we can
demonstrate that we know what you're
going to say
then it isn't a thought worthy of a
human right
if we can predict you and it's not by
virtue of us having modeled some
beautiful thought process of yours it's
because your thought process looks like
that of
you know an indefinitely large number of
other people who are totally predictable
and that's nothing you should be
comfortable with
i think we this goes back to the
question i asked you at first
which is when you
engage in what i would call independent
first principles thinking
you immediately run into challenges
that somebody who's not deeply involved
in such a thing doesn't intuit
right and so i'm imagining
a person somebody uh
who is decent who has
compassion has all of the basic
capacities you would hope they would
have
who has fallen into one of these
automatic thought patterns and i'm
imagining
you manage to sit down with them and
show them that their thought pattern
is automatic and totally predictable and
therefore nothing that they should be
comfortable with
and let's say that they walk out of the
room
and they start behaving differently and
they start thinking for themselves they
stay awake
right well they're going to run into
some stuff because
they are of course going to end up
landing on some formulations
that as soon as they say them out loud
are going to get them punished
right that is inevitable now those of us
who
live out here learn how to say things in
ways that sometimes the punishments
don't stick
we learn where they are best stated we
learn what
we shouldn't say yet but all of this
speaks to
what i think is it's not we don't live
in an authoritarian
uh state but we live in a state in which
thought
is policed as if we did right
not perfectly but enough that
one who wishes to escape from
the accepted the sanitized
narrative has to be ready
for what happens next and
that's something that is it's very hard
to generate that in other words it's a
developmental process that causes you to
learn how to navigate that space
so somebody who just simply recognizes i
don't want to be an automaton
and i'm going to start thinking for
myself if their next move is to start
thinking for themselves and speaking
openly about it
what comes back next is something for
which we don't have a good response
earlier you said when you were defining
near the beginning of our conversation
what you meant by independent thinker is
someone who
wants to go where
ever the facts and information that are
well verifiable actually leave them
i would say that there there's something
like the spirit of science
which is a reverence and respect for
reality
where i want to know what is real and be
with what's real more than i want to
hold a particular belief no matter how
cherished or whatever in group it
i'm a part of in the the uncomfort of
not belonging with the in-group
if i want to belong with anything i
actually want to have a belonging with
reality first
and a belonging with my own integrity
and then with those who also share that
and that the other belongings that i
give up i don't stop caring about those
people
i care about them still but i don't
necessarily care about their opinion of
me
enough that i'm willing to distort my
own relationship with reality
all right so here's the question i want
to ask about this
and i'm basically trying to surface some
part of my own
process in order to figure out what it
is can it be improved
can i teach it to others to the extent
that it works
there are so i was on
bill maher with heather last friday
and i said something that got an awful
lot of pushback
online which i knew was coming i said
he asked if i thought the probability
that coveted 19
was the result of a lab leak was at
least 50 percent and i said something
quite honest and shouldn't have been new
to anybody who'd been
paying attention to my channel which was
that i had said back in june
that i thought the chances were at least
90 percent
now i can imagine that that number would
be
shocking to many people but i also know
that where i in their shoes
i would process it this way i would say
all right this person seems intelligent
i don't know of a conflict of interest
that number is way off of what i would
calculate
therefore i need to file this as a flag
do i not know
something maybe the person has a
conflict of interest and that explains
it
but if it's not that how have they
arrived at a number that is so far off
of what i would calculate
and what does it tell me in other words
i would become
agnostic at that moment rather than go
on the attack
people don't give enough benefit of the
doubt to people who agree
who think differently and they give too
much trust to those who think the same
right but then here's the the place that
the thought goes
so is it true that if somebody
intelligent says something um
that is completely inconsistent with my
model
of the universe that i will inherently
give it enough credence
to look at it it's a tough question
because if i
if i try some test cases if you told me
that uh you believed that there was a
strong chance that the earth was flat
okay that would throw a huge error for
me right
because i know a that i've checked
right in fact i have years ago and
several times said what are the chances
there's anything that these flat
earthers
that they're not just a joke and then
it's a trivial matter to find out what
you need to know from your own
experience that is inconsistent with
that possibility and so the answer is
okay
i'm not going to spend too much time
checking with it right
then we get to is the moon landing fake
right this one is tougher right it's
tougher because when you look
at the actual evidence that people are
motivated to hypothesize
the moon landing is fake there are some
things in it that are hard to know i
don't often know what the explanation
for them is
so anyway my point is there are some
ideas i wouldn't be shocked at all
to find that you believe there's some
ideas i would be so shocked that i would
imagine you're kidding
or um you've lost your mind or
i don't know what and so we all draw
that line somewhere and i guess my point
is i think
almost everybody even very very smart
people
who don't happen to be experienced in
first principles independent thinking
draw that line somewhere that creates
a fatal error when independence
is experimented with right
that the number of things that you know
it is the matrix in some sense once you
start experimenting with what would i
conclude if i was
independent of all incentives and i just
went based on the evidence and i gave
everybody a chance to articulate their
position
what comes back is so jarring that
most people are driven back into
conventional automatic thinking
because the the frightening aspects of
what
what they get in response are enough to
drive them
off the instinct
yes okay god there's so much in here
that's really good
the thing about the flat earth is that
it is
the hypothesis is formally falsifiable
and the alternative even by an
individual yes
and it's though the alternative
hypothesis is formally verifiable with
the best methods that we have with
the highest confidence we can have
and now one thing i would still say is
interesting is
i know many people who refer to flat
earthers as the
moniker of maximum stupidity who cannot
do the copernican
proof so they take as an article of
faith
that the earth is round but they
actually don't know how to drive it have
never tried and so
then they also moved to taking as an
article of faith similar things that
don't have the same basis
so if so does someone even understand
what falsifiable and verifiable mean
does someone have a basis for
calibrating their confidence margin
because if if i start to talk about
um
the moon landing or then i go a little
bit further and talk about
long-term autoimmune effects or
epigenetic drift or whatever they come
from a vaccine schedule of 72 vaccines
together
is the standard narrative falsifiable
or verifiable is the alternate narrative
falsifiable in the way flat earth is no
so the fact that we put flat earth and
anti-vax in the same category is a
intellectually dishonest bad thing to do
and um but the fact that most people
don't even know how to do verify or
falsify and so like
with the lab hypothesis when you come to
90 i'm guessing you have a process for
that
what i would say is i haven't studied it
enough to put a percentage because i
don't have enough bayesian priors
to actually come up with a mathematical
number what i would say is
i consider the idea of
it coming from a lab and some kind of
dual function gain
gate of function research dual purpose
gain and function
to be very plausible and
i have seen nothing that falsifies that
and the few attempts that i saw early to
falsify it were theoretically invalid to
me
now to be able to go from plausible to a
probability number i would need to apply
different epistemic tools than i have
already applied well wait a second
i'm not sure that that's the case
because
the to me as
a theoretician there is a hypothesis
the there are multiple hypotheses one is
the virus escaped from a lab unmodified
another is that it was enhanced with
gain of function research
and then it escaped another is that it
was weaponized
and deliberately released all of these
things each of them is a hypothesis
each of them makes predictions and they
are all testable
now i am not required to have
any guess as to which one will turn out
to be correct
nor an assessment of how probable it is
it is natural to have a guess but the
two things function
independently right as a scientist i am
obligated to treat
a hypothesis by the formal rules of
science i know what they are
i know how they work and therefore i
know at what point it's
going to be falsified any one of them
and what would be necessary for one of
them to become a theory that is to say
for all of its challengers to fall
now i can also say look
if i had to bet here's where i'd put my
money but i'm not
i'm i happen to be a scientist who would
be placing a bet but my bet is not a
scientific bet
yeah so we're we're aligned
clarification agreed yeah
okay good so that that is that is my
hunch that i didn't come to that number
through
a actual bayesian or other kind of
mathematical process but
if i was actually trying to formally
give my
my percentage basis i would go through
some epidemic process and then
now if i had to make a consequential
choice based on it
the more consequential the choice is the
more process i would want to go through
to calibrate my confidence of it because
the more problematic it would be for me
to be wrong
right okay so that that all makes sense
but the
the ultimate question here is given that
we can see
we want people not to behave in an
automatic way
in a uh a way that is
below the nature of human cognition's
capacity
to to think and to react but we also
know
that when people experiment with that
under the current regime
it is not that they will produce
conclusions that are different than they
would otherwise produce say them to
their friends
and their friends will say oh that's
interesting i didn't realize you think
that
their friends will say oh my god i can't
believe you're one of them
right and that that thing is so powerful
that it is
artificially depressing the degree of
independent thought because anybody who
has experimented with it is likely to
have effectively
you know touched some third rail and
retreated
um as a response so we don't know
there's a failure mode on both sides
there's a failure mode
of not of creating artificial
constraints where we don't explore the
search base widely enough
which is the one you're mentioning
there's another one of exploring the
search base without appropriate vetting
and jumping from hypothesis to theory
too fast yes and those two are reacting
against each other
right there are people who say
because it's plausible it is they jump
from hypothesis straight to theory
without
proof and then they believe wacky ass
hit
yes and they insist that it's true and
then people over here
are like wow that's really dangerous and
dreadful and anything that looks like
that i'm going to reject offhand
and similarly people over here believe
standard models that end up getting
either captured or at least limited and
people over here react against that so
this is another place that i would say
the polls are driving each other both to
nonsensical positions
well yes and the way that works in
practice
is there is a team that
in principle knows that it is in favor
of doing the analysis but it does not
believe itself
capable of doing the analysis so
effectively it signs up for the
authority of those who claim to have
done the analysis and in principle have
the right degrees or whatever
but then we run into this thing which
goes back to something you've said in
several places in this discussion
which has to do with the bias amongst
those
involved in certain behavior in other
words if you're
an epidemiologist at the moment or a
virologist
there's a very strong chance that you
believe the lab leak hypothesis
is stands a very low chance
of being true but you also very likely
have a conflict of interest you may be
directly involved in the research
program
that would have generated covet 19
or you may simply be involved in social
circles in which there is a desire
not to have virologists responsible for
this pandemic
and therefore there's a circling of the
wagons that has nothing to do
with analysis but either way the
tendency
to converge on a consensus is
completely unnatural and those who are
trying
who earnestly are trying to follow
science end up following consensus
delivered by people who claim the mantle
of science while not doing the method
and that is a terrible hazard
yeah yeah i agree and there's one step
worse which is the thing that we
mentioned earlier which is you can do
the method
have them all of the data coming out of
the method be right and still have the
answer be misrepresentative of the whole
because you either studied the wrong
thing or you studied something too
partial
and so this question of what is worth
trusting
comes up again and is um
okay i i don't want to defect on my own
sense-making to
just join the consensus so that i am not
rejected
at the same time if everyone is sure
that i'm wrong
and i'm sure that i'm right i should pay
attention to that
right because very possibly i have a
blind spot and i'm a confused narcissist
um every once in a while
they are all in an echo chamber and i'm
actually seeing something
and it's it both can be the case
sometimes so you're like okay
do i always stick to my guns or do i
always take whatever the peer review
says neither
this is again the optimization function
isn't it wisdom
ends up being a i don't know the answer
to this trolley problem before i get
there
right so what i have to say is
is the basis by which the other people
all agreed that you were wrong
deliberative and methodological and
earnest
and free of motivated reasoning does it
have a group motivated reasoning that's
associated with it
are there you know clear blind spots in
the thing you're thinking so
i i don't think there's an answer to the
what actually is right there there is no
methodology it's the doubt that's
eternal is not
that the speaker's not the eternal doubt
the methodology that's formalizable
is not the thing that reveals the the
tao right like
ultimately you have to end up adding
placebo at a certain point and then
double blinding and then randomization
the methods have to keep getting better
because
there's always something in the letter
of the law that doesn't get the spirit
of the law
and then the letter of the methodology
that doesn't get actual science right
right and in fact so a couple things
here one
there's a part of the scientific method
which is a black box
there's a part that actually i believe
literally cannot be taught
right it is the part where you formulate
a hypothesis
right that is a that is a
personal process if i taught somebody to
do it my way that i don't think they do
it very well
right so the point is that's something
that you learn to do
through some process that is mostly not
conscious hard to
hard to teach and hard to discover but
everybody who does it well does it in
some different way
and so at that level even just saying do
the method
is incomplete because not everybody can
do the method
um see there was something else
uh oh yeah
there was there was a missing thing on
your list i realized you weren't trying
to be exhausted but there was a missing
thing on the list of possible reasons
that you could come up against a
consensus and still be right even if
you're the only person who disagrees
and it has to do with the
non-independence of the data points on
the other side
based on let's say either a perverse
incentive
or a school of thought having won out
and killed off all of the diversity of
thought over some issue that turns out
to matter
and these things can very easily so i
would say yes
if you always think you're right and
when everybody's against you
uh they're wrong then yeah narcissism is
a strongly likely reason
on the other hand it is as you point out
with tesla
and their competitors
sometimes you find that a field or an
industry is easy to beat
that there's something about them that
is you know maybe economically very
robust
but with respect to their capacity has
become feeble
and this is true again and again in
scientific fields that scientific fields
go through a process where they
a school of thought delivers
handsomely on some insight
it wins the power to own the entire
field
that insight runs its course diminishing
return sets in
it stops delivering anything new it
doesn't
give up the reins and hand them over to
somebody else because there's no
mechanism to do that so the people
who have the school of thought that's
already burned out its value
stick to their you know their power
and that means that the field is wide
open
to be beaten by an outsider who just
simply isn't
required to subscribe to whatever the
assumptions of the school of thought are
and that happens so frequently that
there is this
it's artificially common that you have
the experience if you think
independently and you know what you're
doing
that you'll disagree with just about
everybody and they'll actually turn out
to be wrong because
they're proceeding from a a bad set of
assumptions
so i think this is actually one of the
most interesting applications of
blockchain or decentralized ledger
technology is this idea of an open
science platform
so imagine every time someone did a
measurement
the fundamental measurement it had to be
entered into a blockchain and then the
other places that independently did it
was entered into a blockchain so it was
uncorruptable
and then the the axioms
and the kind of logical propositions get
entered in
and then the logical processes of
whether i'm using
an inductive or a deductive or what
abductive process gets put in
and then we get to kind of look at the
progression of knowledge
then at any point we come to realize
that a previous thing in there was wrong
some data was misentered or a hypothesis
has proved wrong
now we can come back to that point and
look at everything downstream from it
and reanalyze it
um of course you still have the oracle
problem of the entry in in the first
place so if i'm doing motivated science
and i get some answers i don't like and
i can hide them and not enter them
then that'll happen so you still have to
have then
the proper entry into the system but
this addresses something with the
integrity of science and also the
integrity
of government and government spending
and the capture of market forces
of the regulators rather than the
regulators being able to regulate the
market
is we only know when the [ __ ] up thing
happens if we can see it
and which means that everyone who wants
to do something asymmetric or predatory
has a maximum incentive for
non-transparency
so certain kinds of uncorruptability and
transparency are very interesting in
what they can do
towards that interesting now this
actually comes back to something i
wanted to raise
earlier but didn't get to it which is
i started out very focused on
sustainability
i believe sustainability is something
that the system
you can't you can't measure to finely
if you measure too finely then
sustainability becomes an absurd
block to progress because you can't dig
a hole in your own backyard because
you couldn't dig a million such holes
but if you relax the system so that
you're measuring processes that actually
potentially matter
sustainability has to be a feature of
the system long term right it doesn't
have to be the
feature of the system in any given time
period but overall
it has to net uh to a sustainable
mode i wouldn't say a system has to be
sustainable i would say
the meta system or increasing orderly
complexity has to be sustainable but
that might mean a system intentionally
obsoleting itself for a new better
system
okay i accept that but what i've
realized
uh down this road is that the system
actually
or the set of systems or the meta system
however you want to describe it
needs a fail-safe which i call
reversibility
right so the point is if you set the
goal of sustainability
and you say well we have to measure
things that matter sooner or later
you're going to fail to measure
something that matters and you're going
to deal with it unsustainably
and at the point that you figure it out
it's going to be too late
so my point would be
and you know this is a tough one people
don't like the implications of this if
they understand it
but any process that you set in motion
has to be something you could undo if it
turns out to be harmful in a way that
you didn't see coming
right so that is to say you can alter
the atmosphere
carbon dioxide is not poisonous
right the changes in concentration that
change the degree of heat trapping
are not um terribly meaningful
to the well-being of living creatures
but at the point you discover that the
heat trapping is going to massively
change the way
uh the atmosphere functions and the
oceans etc etc
you have to be able to undo it now undo
it means you could change the
concentration back to what it was now
what this would mean in practice was
that
you would have to slow the process of
change down
such that you scaled up the process that
would reverse
the change in proportion now if you
imagine
all of the disasters that we have faced
all the ones i
named up top and all of the other ones
that look like it from
you know fukushima to aliso canyon
to financial collapse of 2008 and you
imagine
that in proportion to the process that
went awry we had scaled up the reversal
process so that it was there
if we needed it right we would have been
in a very different
situation because a the process would
have run away much much slower
and b the tools to undo it would have
been present and ready
oh before you respond to that i do want
to say that the only way that that would
work
is if it was over the entire system in
other words if
one nation for example were to decide
that it had to adhere to a standard of
reversibility while other nations
weren't restricted in the same way
you didn't you'd get a tragedy of the
commons where the
atmosphere or whatever other resource
would ultimately be destroyed by the
nations that didn't participate in that
system
and the nation that was most responsible
would pay the cost of uh building a
reversibility system that wouldn't work
in the end
but other than that i think the
principle makes sense
what do you think so something like
sustainability having a consideration
like reversibility as one of the
factors to inform choice making
and that that is a is a valuable
consideration
and that it doesn't matter at all if we
don't have collective coordination
capacity to be able to make the right
choices
period so yes agreed now
regarding reversibility i think
reversibility is a valuable
consideration
that is
um
impossible and important ways
but it's still an important
consideration so
can i decrease the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere if we realize we need to
kind of yes but
the co2 in the atmosphere went up along
with a lot of mountaintop removal
mining for coal and a lot of species
extinction in the process
a lot of people who died over wars for
oil can i reverse and get those dead
people back and those extinct species
back and those pristine ecosystems back
nope they're gone and then also
reversibility over what time frame
will new old growth forests come back
thousands of years from now
sure does that time scale matter um
if i ever extinct a species is that
reversible
um does every species matter what about
killing an individual
element within it you know so it's like
um
i can only think about reversibility on
very narrowly defined metrics but the
thing that harms that one metric has
lots of other effects simultaneously
and so we have to understand the
reversibility by its
by itself is an oversimplification
because we'll always be thinking upon
metrics that are subsets of all that's
affected
yep i agree uh it is
a it is a oversimplification as is
sustainability but my sense is that you
have to instantiate it in some way in
order for the system to be safe and i
would say
if it prevents you from removing
mountaintops
as long as it prevents everybody else
from removing mountaintops it's
the right idea in other words if we are
allowed to
degrade the earth a little bit at a time
by
removing mountaintops now and you know
drying up rivers
next time then eventually you have a
world that isn't very
worth living in and i do believe that we
have a moral
obligation not to degrade the planet
right that that our highest moral
obligation has to be to deliver
the capacity to live a complete
fulfilling human
life to as many people as we can and
that means
not um liquidating the planet it means
a renewal process which is the very
definition of sustainability
and it's inconsistent with um removing
mountaintops now
lots of species don't matter
right there are lots of little offshoots
of species and they can go extinct and
they do go extinct and nobody is
harmed by their doing so which it's not
the same thing as
losing orcas or you know elephants or
eagles or whatever so obviously you need
to have a
a rational threshold in which you
protect against
um against degradation
and allow degradation that doesn't have
an important implication
but the question is really is it so
compromised by those considerations that
it's not worth considering or is it
rescuable
if one figures out how to apply a
threshold
so we said that one of the dialectics
that defines the
left and right in its most abstract form
generally
has to do with a focus on the individual
versus a focus on society or the
collective or the tribe or some kind of
group
another one is an orientation
towards conservation or
conservativeness traditionalness an
orientation on the other side towards
progress or progressiveness and again
these are confused all over the place
and even what we call left and right
have shifted in the last
you know a few decades in a number of
ways but
it's interesting here because when you
talk about
reversibility and sustainability another
synonym is conservation what is it that
we want to be able to conserve
and so the conservative principle is
focused on
what has made it through evolution that
is valuable enough that we should
conserve it not [ __ ] it up and
yet so interestingly the people who are
often called conservatives
are not focused on critical aspects of
conservation
um but if you you're talking about
biosphere conservation right now
oftentimes they're talking about
sociosphere conservation the
conservation of social systems
and you're saying that underneath it is
the capacity for humans to thrive and
have meaningful lives and relationships
and we would say that that is a function
of the biosphere the socio-sphere and
the technosphere and the relationship
between them
and so and we can say very clearly it's
the technosphere ruining
the biosphere most of the time and yet
if it ruins the biosphere enough the
technosphere goes because the
technosphere depends upon the biosphere
so we have to learn how to make a
technological built environment that is
replenishing regenerative with the
biosphere
and the sociosphere is another really
critical one
i think you'll probably actually have
something to add to this i haven't
thought of when i think of what the
fundamental intuition of a conservative
is
even if they don't articulate it like
this
and the traditionalist kind of impulse
which is
let's go back to the constitution let's
go back to
christianity or european ideas or the
free market or whatever it is
uh or rigorous monogamy whatever social
structure lasted for a long time
that there there's an intuition even if
they don't formally think of it this way
logically
that almost everything didn't make it
through evolution in terms of social
systems and the few things that did
weren't the things that people thought
would so there's a lot of embedded
wisdom that wasn't understood that was
very hard
earned and we want to preserve that and
not break it because we think we
understand it well enough and we might
not
and that fundamentally the progressive
intuition is that we're dealing with
fundamentally novel situations that
evolution didn't already figure out and
we need innovation
and of course the synthesis of that
dialectic is we need new innovation
that is commensurate with that which
should be conserved and not everything
should be conserved
because some things made it through
because they won short-term battles
while [ __ ] up the long-term hole
and so what things are worth being
conserved what things are not worth
being conserved did we understand it
well enough that we didn't say this
isn't worth being conserved out of
hubris
and then what progress is commensurate
with that
i think is a good way of thinking about
that dialectic
yeah i like it and i think there's the
flip side of it as well which is
that captured inside uh biblical
traditions
are some bits of some basically
responses to game theoretic hazards that
are consistent with things we've talked
about so for example
the christian sense that not only is the
world here for
humans to make use of but that we are in
effect
obligated to do it
that belief fits perfectly in a world
where if your population doesn't capture
a resource somebody else is going to so
in other words
that belief structure travels along with
a tendency to capture the resources that
are available
and to the extent that what that does is
it causes the exploitation of a resource
the tools with which those resources
could have been exploited in biblical
times
almost always left a system that would
return itself to equilibrium
given an opportunity which isn't true in
the modern circumstance so
what we have is a place where there's
lots of
stuff that is um
conservative that there's a very good
and often hidden reason that we should
preserve
and then there are some places where
we'd actually have to upgrade the wisdom
because it doesn't fit modern
circumstances
and the conservation of the natural
world
is i think a clear case
just because you mentioned this case
when when
people realize that christendom spread
largely by holy war not exclusively but
largely
you need a religion that makes a lot of
people that are willing to die in holy
war because of a good afterlife
and who you can spare right a lot large
population of people that can die and
war
and islam and christianity both had this
they both had
um be fruitful and multiply and
proselytize
because they both had war as a strategy
for propagation of the memes
so you needed numbers whereas judaism
didn't have it
right and quakerism and some other ones
didn't judaism had to
actually make it hard for people to join
the religion
because you're not going to lose a lot
of people as soldiers you're going to
embed yourself as a diaspora within
dominant cultures and end up affecting
the apparatus of those cultures
so it's interesting to think about how
those different memeplexes had different
evolutionary adaptations but it's
important for the reason you mentioned
is that those traditions were influenced
by politics
and economics and war and philosophy and
culture and a lot of things
so you can't wholesale throw them out or
keep them or like you have to actually
understand what allowed those memes to
propagate and what their memetic
propagation dynamics were
and so that conservative impulse it says
the things that made it through made it
through for a reason yes but some of the
things that made it through for a reason
won't keep making it through
dinosaurs were around for a long time
and then they weren't
right so um and as we've mentioned
evolution can be blind and run
very effectively into cul-de-sacs and
yet the other side is
all too often we will criticize
a tradition for being dumb when we don't
understand what made it work well enough
and we throw something out that was
actually
worth not throwing out so how do you do
a deep enough
historical understanding to be able to
decide what should be conserved and not
is is also a really good question it's a
really important question because it's
it's
chesterton's fence factory effectively
right
nobody knows what what actually was
functional and what
you know uh had no function but traveled
along with it because they were paired
very closely
in a biblical text and uh
you know what functioned in ways that we
don't want it to function
now these things are all invisible
because the whole thing
is encoded in myth so it's not in there
right
so yeah that's a huge hazard and it's a
tough one for those of us who want to
build reasonably and recognize that
there's an awful lot that we have to do
that's novel
because it hasn't been accomplished
before we have to grapple with the fact
that it's not like these traditions are
simply backward some of them are very
insightful and non-literal
and uh we need to
exercise great caution caution in
approaching them
okay so i want to come back to your
three generations at least problem
it's easy to look at the nature of the
problems and just
assume that we are [ __ ] and usually to
tie that to
some conversation about human nature and
to say okay well we were able to figure
out
technology that was extraordinarily
powerful to speak mythopoetically the
power of gods
the nuke was clearly the power of gods
right and then lots of texans then we
can genetically engineer new species
gain a function whatever
without the love and wisdom of gods that
goes in a self-terminate direction
is it within the capacity of our nature
to move towards the love and wisdom of
gods to bind that power
or are we inexorably inadequate
vessels for the amount of power we have
so
then i do a positive deviant analysis to
look at
what are the best stories of human
nature to see if they converge in the
right
direction and then also
where there are conditioning factors
that we take for granted because they
become ubiquitous
and think that they're nature so if we
if we go back to the bible for a moment
we look at jews
and we look at was there a population of
people that were able to
educate all of their people at a higher
level than most other people around them
for a pretty long time in lots of
different circumstances
yes you look at the buddhists were there
a population of people that across
millennia and different environments
were able to make everybody peaceful
enough to not hurt bugs
yes across all the genetic variants and
across all of the economic factors and
whatever else do we have examples
a very high level of cognitive
development and very high level of
ethical development of different
populations based on cultures
we do and then we say oh well but
you know look at how well the founding
fathers ideas failed here
well the the comprehensive education of
everyone is not in the interests of the
elite that have the most power as we
mentioned and so
making it seem like that that's an
impossible thing is actually really good
to support the idea that there should be
some kind of nobility or aristocracy or
something like that there should be to
control because they're more qualified
i would say that we have not in modern
times ever tried
to educate our population in a way that
could lead to self-governance because
there was no incentive to do so or those
who had the most capacity had incentive
to do something else even when they said
they were doing that
so do i think that it's possible do i
think that we have examples historically
of people who
developed themselves cognitively and
ethically enough that if we did those
together
right buddhist jews however we want to
talk about it do i think that's possible
within human nature and
basically untried yes
yeah i love that and i agree with you
it's dependent on something which we
might as well
spell out here which is that
the capacities the difference in
capacity between human populations
is overwhelmingly if not entirely at the
software level which i firmly believe
i'm speaking as a biologist i've looked
at this i will have to defend it at
length elsewhere but the degree to which
it's software that distinguishes us and
therefore
we can innovate tools we can democratize
tools all of that is at our disposal and
i agree with you it hasn't been tried
and it might be our only hope but at
least we've got prototypes
now i will say why i'm grateful for what
happened at evergreen
is that you wouldn't be here doing this
otherwise and on bill maher
and you're you and heather are both
exceptional educators and so the fact
that your tiny little niche for
education got blown up so that you took
this quality of education to all the
people who were interested
uh this larger scale i'm really happy
about because i'm my friend
this exact thing is the thing that has a
chance is
a strange attractor of those who are
called to a cultural enlightenment
starting to be come to a come together
in a way that can then lead them to
coordinate to build systems that can
then propagate those
possibilities for other people well i
really appreciate that and i
uh i must say i feel it as a calling
as i'm certain you do and so
uh yes and i also love the point that
you made earlier about the fact that the
audience for this
really is people uh seeking
a kind of uh enlightenment and community
and so yes um as much as you and i both
focus on
uh existential risks there is hope in
that
yeah okay daniel well this is uh i think
we've gone more than
three hours it's certainly been a great
conversation and there are so many
threads that are worth revisiting which
we should do
sooner rather than later this was super
fun i really enjoyed it
yeah it was um so daniel schmuckenberger
where can people find you
well you mentioned in the beginning we
have something called the consensus
project that will be launching
soon uh via a newsletter in march and
then a website in a few months
um so tune back in on that and it's a
it is a project in the space a
non-profit project that is seeking to
do a better job of news with education
built in so we actually make the
epistemics we
look at very complex issues that are
polarized and we make the epistemics
that we're applying
explicit so we're actually teaching
people how do you sense make complex
situations in situ
and then if anyone ever thinks we missed
any of the data about something wrong
they can let us know and we'll publicly
correct it and credit them if that's
right
etcetera so um and the goal there is
helping to catalyze cultural
enlightenment of this type and
recognizing that both education and
fourth estate are requisite structures
for open society and open society
being rebooted has to be rebooted at the
cultural level first
um right now uh
you can find me on facebook
or one of those platforms or have a blog
an old blog everything's out of date on
it civilizationemerging.com
civilizationemerging.com and uh are you
not on twitter and does that explain how
you're so clear-headed
i'm not on twitter um and
i'm on facebook because it
uh because of metcalf law um because
everyone is so it ends up being a useful
introduction and messaging tool
but yeah i'm not part of the twitter
crew more power to you
all right daniel this has been a
pleasure and i look forward to our next
one
uh be well and uh everybody else
thanks for tuning in thanks